uh hey what's going on it's bill burns
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm just checking in with
you
with uh
just an absolute absolute absolute
legend
um something that i discovered late
night on youtube and ended up getting
her into f is for family from the band
the underrated band that influenced all
of these all female bands
um um fanny is the name of the band and
we have the great
drummer of the band alistair birth thank
you so much for coming on
um
i can't even tell you like how blown
away i was by your band and that the
ridiculousness that you guys have not
gotten your due you guys came on the
scene late 60s in the early 70s
and absolutely crushed it
um i was watching the video and i was
seeing june millington
playing slide guitar killing it her
sister gene on base and then uh nikki
barclay on uh keys and then you on drums
total legit uh just watching like you
guys absolutely
[ __ ] rocked
what can you explain to me and everybody
else how the hell you guys were that
good
and you don't get your recognition other
than the obvious but like you know
people still know the runaways
they know
we were we were ten years too early
oh okay we and we didn't write songs
that were pop songs
we were played on fm radio
not am radio san diego a.m back then was
where all the pop stuff was
yeah and that's where the money went
oh okay yeah all the department's
budgets went to good on am radio
what was it like
um
were there any other all-female groups
around back then that didn't push
yeah um bertha was another band from la
and uh they were around i think they
started right after us i know that they
signed a record deal a year or two after
we had
um and they played
even a heavier
rock and roll our songs you listen to
our songs today and
you could call qualify them as kind of
pop rock
right no they're not heavy metal
like you like to play yeah
i know
sorry that's when i grew up
but hey
um
we found out mike pierce
your twitter
tweeted uh kristen
from the get behind fanny podcast mike
price yeah mike price mike price not
pierce he um
[Music]
told her that we're the first
real
people
to be on f is for family
oh as far as like being actually playing
the people that you're playing yeah
absolutely
so
i i don't want to give away too much but
like uh
you know there's people who are into the
band and stuff so they go to a concert
and we have you guys playing and you
guys are are in the episode and what i'm
hoping
we can do as a small part is to uh get
people to be like hey who's that band
oh yeah for you guys to uh get the
recognition that that uh
that eluded you for so long but um
anyway if there's anybody just sort of
start from the beginning like where um
how did all you guys
get together and as a female drummer
back then in rock music and everything
and you're setting out you know just to
make it in show business in general is
like you're
taking a one in a million chance and
then you have all of this you know all
this sexism and all that crap you have
to deal with
yeah like i mean there was a lo there
was a time where the people like i think
only until like recently they were like
you know chicks don't know how to play
drums
[Laughter]
i chicks out in school in second grade
and i had an all-girl trio in iowa which
is where i was born and raised
and i packed my clothes inside my drums
before i turned 18 i was still 17 and i
moved to california because i knew
nothing was going to happen in iowa
so i moved to sacramento and
junior i gave you that what gave you the
inner strength
at 18
to leave
iowa
at 18 and just say i know this is what i
you just knew what you wanted to do
no no no it had nothing to do with inner
strength it had to do with escaping
because i had just come out as a lesbian
in a small town and
i couldn't stay
that way when you do what you your
parents
or you just said to the whole town did
you go down to the gazebo
in the people of small town iowa all 40
of you
so um
it's kind of a sordid story that i don't
want we don't want to bring the
you know
friday morning well if you want to tell
it i would love to hear it i think you
know there's people going through that
still to this day so maybe it'll help
somebody well um i was 17 i had never
had a sexual experience my first sexual
experiences with a woman an older woman
and she left behind her family and
went had cousins in sacramento
and i was the day out of the
psychopathic board of the state hospital
where my mother had put me
because you said you were gay
yeah and she she didn't know how to help
me
i didn't didn't know that at the time
because it was really painful but anyway
long story short
they said well what was the psych ward
like
oh man it was it was like creepy
it was you're locked in
you know steel uh
screens on the windows
you know and the doctors all they wanted
to talk about was sex and i didn't want
to talk about sex at all
you know
thank you very much no
[Laughter]
so anyway
uh the woman came back from california
and
got me
and the doctors had said let her go so i
packed everything i owned that i thought
i'd need
inside my drums put them in her car and
we sweated it we were escaping literally
you're like i don't want to stick around
here maybe they'll change their mind and
stick me back in that place exactly yeah
it was horrible holy [ __ ]
yeah that's why i'm a little warped that
plus being a female drummer
in an all-female band
in hollywood in the late 60s and early
70s
warped yeah just a little
[Laughter]
were you able to uh
patch things up with uh small town iowa
as people i guess
learned
hopefully
um
a couple years ago
um one of
this woman's daughters was killed and
somebody commented
oh yeah she's the one the one that ran
away with the beer girl back in the day
and so no with my family yes
absolutely no problems with my family
right yeah that was all healed
no problems at all
well that's that's good that families
the hell with the townspeople as long as
your family
yeah it's a small small-minded small
town
all right okay so then you get in the
car you do the thelma louise thing right
oh yeah yeah
yeah you're escaping a psych ward it's a
great beginning of a movie by the way
yeah you're escaping a psych ward it
feels like a grind house uh tarantino
movie yeah um
and you end up unfortunately you end up
in sacramento
yeah well fortunately
because june and jean lived in
sacramento oh okay and i put a i saw a
sign at a music store that said looking
for a female drummer so i called their
little sister took the message didn't
give it to them they went on a canadian
tour and i think they went through five
different drummers mostly guys
but when they came back they contacted
me i auditioned
and we started playing as this felts
well addy and i
the the lead guitar
we got tired of the june and jean show
and so we split away from them into wild
hunting
we realized about four months later that
that was not going to work so we mended
fences got back together as wild honey
how were you able to do that
because you walked away from them i
imagine the feeling how much time had
gone by
when you guys
left and then were able to come back six
months max
so how did you approach them to get back
together like hey man we made a mistake
and they made a mistake too they
realized it too i mean it was all we all
realized that
what was the glue was the four of us
right and then by that point the woman
that i had come from iowa with was
involved with addie the lead guitar
player
and when we fired her after we got to la
and got the recording contract
then the lead guitar player quit and
that's when june had to learn how to let
play lead and she did it
so fast if you listen to the first album
june's leads are
fantastic
you know
um
she and she took that weight on
and i don't think that she ever really
let herself breathe
um because after four albums and touring
and stuff she couldn't take it anymore
and she just had a meltdown and she quit
and after she quit then i quit
but you know the four albums the four
original members
that's
the group that created that
really
unique and magical fanny sound right and
when you were you putting on an album
like every like 18 months or was it
every year during that time with the
touring and all of that the first one
came out in 70
right and the fourth one came out in 73.
so we were touring we were rehearsing we
were recording and that's all we did
seven days a week oh my god i'm
surprised you lasted four years why did
they do that i've never understood the
music world why they
didn't let you breathe because every
band that i watched
it was just like yeah they had that
first album came out and then the world
win like three four years and a couple
more albums with world tours and then
somebody would leave someone would just
invariably just be like like dude this
isn't fun anymore
like i wanted to play music because
yeah it was fun and and i always i
always find that like a fascinating
thing like
you know that you went after a dream and
they go hey you go after a dream you're
never going to work again and it's just
like until it becomes
this thing that other people are also
making money off of
you know and then you just keep like
and then you got that weird thing where
it's like how do i get off this
you're afraid to say no because you
think if you say no you're going to go
back to your small town iowa like the
second i
pump the brakes
everybody behind me is going to blow by
me and i think like that that's like a
maturity move in this business when
you've finally realized like no hey i
can work at my own pace
i'm confident in my talent
that i'm going to be able to keep going
um
but i just found with bands because it's
it's i think it's easier for a comedian
being an individual because whatever i
decide it's a hundred percent agreement
within myself where you guys have to
have like a
well the dynamics
were
difficult from the minute we got nikki
nikki didn't want to be in an all-girl
bed
she wanted to be the lead
artist with all the spotlight on her
she was a keyboard piano player right
and yeah and she wrote the real rockers
june wrote more of the ballads if nicki
and june had been able to get along and
write songs together
you know i can't imagine
they wrote a couple songs one of them
was i just realized which i love that
song it's got a great beat and great
lyrics
but they were always at loggerheads and
i think that
you know when the
record company wanted to put us in
skimpy outfits
on the last tour so why couldn't why
can't i wear a t-shirt and jeans that's
i'm more comfortable in a t-shirt and
jeans
now i've got this little top that's made
out of 45 worth of american coins looped
together pinching my nipples
do i have to do this really
and i think that was the straw that
broke jun's back and she just said i
can't do this anymore
and was um
and when she left then you left and then
the whole band was was um
was nikki still into it at that point
even though they wanted to do
nikki and jean played on the fifth album
yeah oh okay but it doesn't sound
anything like a fanny album at all
it's it's which is a credit
to both you and june because some of my
favorite bands
you know went on for a long time and um
you know i i just the
[Music]
just changing the drummer if you have a
really good drummer
yeah the band never sounds the same like
tom petty never sounded the same once
stan lynch left
um i've recently gotten into early iron
maiden
and i was listening to uh clive burr and
i was just like and then you listen like
that moment when
uh
nicole mcbrain comes in it's just like
it is
it's funny and he did a lot of the same
sort of like
things but their feel i still love
maiden with with nickel but it's just
it's two different bands it really is
guns and roses with stephen adler not in
it
um
yeah i mean you you can't i mean that's
why zeppelin was so smart they're like
we can't continue on the way we were
this is just it's not gonna
it's not gonna work and i always felt
like uh
why
their catalog maybe
is held in the esteem that it is is
because they didn't go on with all of
these different uh
variations but i understand the bands
that want to keep doing it you want to
keep making them what are you going to
go get a job at a hardware store you
know you want to you didn't make any
money
we made no money
they paid
i moved out of fannie hill and they paid
my rent and they've made my paid my car
payment and if i had you know a doctor
or something they would pay that bill
but the last tour i think we might have
made 25 bucks a night
and that was it and it was so how did
you eat
um
[Music]
well
june used to make candles
and sell them at the swap meet
and i'm thinking reprise paid for
it was the house was 400 a month
up there on on marmot lane
and that's your famous house where you
guys were at right next to the chateau i
actually drove by and found it yeah you
did
yeah yeah
i thought that was so cool i'm so like
that there's so much history there
in the uh the hollywood hills but anyway
so continuously she would sell candles
he sold candles for a while and quite
frankly i don't know if we had
some kind of a
food budget i don't remember that i know
might be something like that but it
wasn't much we'd go down to the central
market and buy enough food for
a week or two
and then we'd cook it and eat
so how often would you guys sit around
being like hey man we're on like a third
or fourth record we're making 25 bucks a
week
what the [ __ ]
yeah um
i think that on the fourth album is when
we started to say what the [ __ ]
did um
the record labels string you along with
each album going like this next one you
know it's gonna be tour buses and plenty
of money you just you just got to pay
off that advance
no roy uh silver who was our manager he
had to fight
every for every penny
to get reprieves and there's a funny
story that christian tells
um
that
he went to reprise to have me to try and
get 50 000 to promote the mother's pride
the last album
and joe smith said you know i'm sorry i
can't do it
so roy got home and he gets a call from
joe smith and he said come back come
back over the hill so i went back over
to reprise and joe smith said
i'll give you the 50 000 for the tour
but you got to promise me you won't put
any more get behind fanny stickers in
the executive bathroom
[Laughter]
so we got to we did the last tour so
although
what's amazing to me though is you guys
had all this ridiculous like credibility
like david bowie was a huge banner you a
few huge fan of your band i think dated
one of the the band members of i
remember yeah and it was just like he
was championing you he championed stevie
ray vaughan
so
is this just straight up sexism like you
know he championed stevie ray and stevie
ray
yeah putting it out there
it's pretty much although you know you
have some hardcore musicians out there
that still cannot believe that a woman
can play
bass or guitar or drums keyboard is kind
of more accepted
but you know
it's like oh yeah they're good for girls
you know and guys are still saying that
today
well you know we're we're insecure
one of the biggest things
secure this buddy
well you know what it is the biggest
thing is if you lose to a girl then
you're just like your whole manhood is
just out the window which is stupid but
that's the rules that we also live by
yeah yeah but you can change the rules
anytime you want
uh yeah i mean i'm up for it
yeah
listen
i grew i looked i grew up and uh yeah it
was even like the 80s it was all
um pretty much
you know all male bands and everything
but then like you know
the like the go-gos and the bangles they
[ __ ] rocked
so
pop songs yeah
the go-go's was
our lips are sealed [ __ ] i i crank
that anytime that comes on
i love that song see the picture in the
corner
my eyes are shut
well that is uh is that the bengals
it's the go-go's the go-go's okay
because i worked at a m records after i
quit playing
and i had to work the go-go's because
they were on irs records
and they told us told me
if it hadn't been for you guys we never
would have thought about putting
picking up instruments and playing
that's amazing so yeah but they wrote
hooks every single one of their top 40
songs had a hook
yeah and we didn't write pop songs
you know i feel i don't know the rock
and roll hall of fame should give you
guys your due they really should there's
something in it
who gives a [ __ ] about the rock mall
hall of fame
it's kind of stupid right
it's all politics it's male
oriented i mean the fact that they
inducted some women this year oh golly
look it was how educated and open and
and you know well they're probably only
doing it because they're getting [ __ ]
for not doing it yeah right i'd like to
give a little bit of [ __ ]
gotta keep this clean though bill no you
don't
no you don't you can say whatever you
want i want people to see what what
you're just a real deal and you're like
such a character i i actually you know
when uh we first met
you know i met you face to face first of
all i called you up and you just started
laughing going how the hell did you find
me how the hell did you guys hear about
my band and all that you immediately
were hilarious and then i met you i
forget whether somewhere in l.a and
you're
huh
we had breakfast at the huntley silly
boy
that's what it was all right well you
know
i know you've been very busy yeah
basically
busy white man busy white man that's
right
and i will be respected no
i was uh the last
last seven eight weeks uh seven out of
eight weeks i've been doing my [ __ ]
jokes out on the road so
um well
i hope that you know the fact that we
got you on this show
will renew people's understanding that
this ban that david bowie was blown away
by
um
i just i i
you know one of the frustrations that i
i've had in you know being in this
business is i just wish they would just
pick the best
and even when they try to be progressive
they even turn that into a formula
so they'll just be like well we haven't
been hiring anybody from this group so
it's like all right well yeah you got to
give them their do right but they won't
take the time
to find
they just kind of they'll have a one
showcase night how many do we need four
all right let's get four asians you know
four african-american it's like do the
[ __ ] work
and get the four that [ __ ] deserve it
yeah as opposed to i don't know why they
they uh
i guess because it's work
giving us caring is work i think is what
it is so they
they're more like bean counting
i i think that what it is is that a lot
of
researchers
have gotten lazy
you know they go to wikipedia and they
think they know the whole story
you know if they go to you know
fannyrocks.com or they listen to the get
behind fanny podcast or they hear some
of our music you know if you listen to
the whole spectrum of the fanny catalog
um
it's
it's very different
it's there are rockers there are ballads
there are sad songs there are happy
songs
you know
but how many people really are going to
do that research not very many but
being on f is for family and i don't
know if you're playing one or two songs
or parts of one or two songs i know that
they had talked about a couple but
anyway um
if
i mean what a gift that is that you're
giving to us
because
somebody sees the name fanny on stage on
f is for family and they say who are
those guys i want to know more and they
do the same deep dive you did
yeah well they they should because i
actually saw you guys come in
and you played live
i got to see you guys a couple of months
back downtown it was great what are you
talking about and you're funny too well
you told me you never like you don't you
don't practice drums you don't like to
even like the way they sound unless
you're playing with other people right
exactly i never practiced
a day in my life until i got my
electronic kit in 2007
and even then i hardly ever play anymore
but how great are those electronic kits
whoa
i mean the headphones on in 2007
i put the headphones on and i had an
ipod and somehow i had gotten the fanny
music
oh maybe it was from the rhino
set that they made anyway i had the
fanny music on my ipod so the ipod was
plugged into the brain
i put the headphones on
my drums never sounded that good and i'm
playing with this i recorded what 45
years ago right it was
amazingly fun i was hooting and
hollering and i wasn't disturbing the
neighborhood yeah
well i first time i sat down i mean you
sound like
you sound like bonham in madison square
garden
on some of them
yeah
yeah the kick drum
and i was just sitting there thinking
like oh my god these are unbelievable
and then i i really thought i was
getting good
and then i sat down on a real kid
[Music]
and it just get all yeah it was
something complete also where the
technology was
was those things in the in the 2000s
electronic drums were so forgiving where
you'd you'd hit a rim and still get the
snare sound so if you were anywhere near
it you'd get it so like your your
precision
really uh suffered now now we get on on
on a real kit and first the drums looks
like they were gigantic and uh
i actually i quickly learned
all right it's simply safe everybody you
know
if you ever wanted to make your home
feel safer there is no better time than
now this week my friends at simply say
for giving my listeners early access to
all their black friday deals 50
off their award-winning home security i
love simply safe because it has
everything you need to make your home
safe indoor and outdoor cameras
comprehensive sensors all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who send help the instant
you need it simply safe was named was
even named best home security system of
2021 by u.s news and world report you
can easily customize a system for your
home online in minutes and even get free
custom recommendations from simply safe
these are simply safe's biggest
discounts of the year you can get a
complete home security system starting
at just over 100 bucks there's no
long-term contracts and commitments it's
a really easy way to start feeling a bit
more peace of mind take advantage of
simply safe's early black friday deals
and get 50 off your new home security
system by visiting
simplysafe.com again that's simply safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr for 50 off your
entire system you know last night i
actually did uh they got a thing out
here called the goddamn comedy jam which
you got to do one time maybe somebody
will do a fanny song is so many
comedians started off as musicians
failed
and then came so you know you obviously
know me i'm a failed drummer so this guy
josh adam i'm drummer
you're a drummer you just don't look
comfortable yeah well yeah it's my hobby
doing your hobby in front of a crowd
well last night i was gonna tell you
um
i had i i played two songs
for josh adameyers who actually plays uh
the dj on f is for family
and um
uh howland hank
um i had a bunch of people come up to me
saying you were smiling you looked all
relaxed and all that stuff i finally
and you know it's funny you know why
because i didn't over rehearse it and i
knew i was gonna [ __ ] up and the song
one of the songs the guns n roses song
mr brownstone and it has and it has like
three different parts to it
but they never happen in the same
sequence it seems so you really have to
pay attention
and and like i kept playing along to it
and i every i i couldn't get a take
where i just did it clean and i was just
like well i'm out of time because i've
been on the road i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ]
this up but who cares and then i ended
up like i don't think i ended up
screwing it up i was literally playing
the song and in sections like i have no
idea what happens next
but i was just like but i know what's
happening now so [ __ ] it
right just play the hell out of this
yeah but see you it's very easy
to
hide a mistake
in a beat or two if you go too much
longer
then the drums drop out and people hear
the mistake but if you realize
that
that you're into that different part of
the song and you catch it
nobody's gonna know yeah
good for you
well you know i learned by watching
people like you
what's the worst you ever messed up and
and did did june or anybody have a look
that they would give you that you knew
you were on that night or they give you
you know remember bonham saying like you
know when he would try some over-the-top
fill
and then he would mess it up he'd say
and then i he goes i get the look from
the lads and it was just
[Music]
no
june bitched about my drum span too loud
a lot okay
but because i played really hard but i
didn't mess up i didn't drop the beat
honey
oh okay oh sorry i didn't even mean to
suggest that oh jesus i was gonna there
you go there you go
hey um
so we've talked a lot about you know all
the
basically the [ __ ] that you met out
there who was you know when you were
coming up
first album 1970 who are some
open-minded cool people that uh you got
to play with
um everybody that we opened for
everybody that we opened for you got any
any band names or anything
i'd have to go on my computer and pull
1971 year oh my god look at that
my journal priceless
yeah
um this is more 71 was more recording
that i'd have publishing and you know
also it's pretty sappy
oh it is yeah it's pretty sappy but
the uh little feet
um
oh who was that drummer richie uh
hayward oh my god
he played the kind of drumming that i
thought oh that's so cool you know that
but
that really syncopated stuff yeah laura
used to get on him and say can't you
just keep the beat like alice does
you know just boom chick boom chick and
a filler too you know what i mean
you don't have to be real busy drums
aren't supposed to delete instruments
but richie was
as they sit there noodling all around in
their guitars
guitar doesn't need to be that way they
want you to shut up so they can do all
the talking
the key is is way to interject i think
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you keep the beat
and you have
a place or two or three or four or five
or ten in a song where you know that a
phil is gonna work
do you know the one time i almost
[ __ ] punched somebody when i was
playing was we were running the song
and the the you know the guy who
considered himself the paul shaffer the
head of the band you know we were just
coming together it was a one-off yeah
i'm not in any band so i was still kind
of playing and he was talking to
somebody reach over and i was riding on
the symbol or whatever he just went over
and he just
muted it with his hand
and i always want to be like dude i'm
going to [ __ ] stab you in the air
with this stick don't ever do that again
just tell me to stop playing he just
came walking
he just went like that and he wasn't
looking at me when he did was it was
such
a passive aggressive power
move that if i was actually making my
living playing drums
that that would have been a big thing
and i was just kind of i just remember
like i just looked down and then i got
to chuckle out of like how mad i was
getting at my hobby like why do i give a
[ __ ]
i don't got to go on the road with this
guy i just got to play one stupid song
with them and also the other thing is
that you have missiles in your hands two
of them oops
oops oh i didn't did i hit you in the
back of the head with that stick i'm so
sorry
leave me the [ __ ] alone i'm playing
drums here
what kind of kit did you play
camco
a camco now did you keep that that brown
one right that's in the video
yeah
do you really i still have it yeah it's
in storage finally all of the drums are
in cases
because i have fantastic plastic bags
and i was thinking the termites were
going to eat that beautiful natural wood
so i went last oh probably about six
months ago and pulled the uh
the floor tones didn't have cases
the especially the 18-inch didn't have a
case
and
the newspaper that it was wrapped in was
1993.
wow
and they were perfect
absolutely perfect and i just cleaned
them up a little bit put them back in
storage you got the hard cases
yeah
oh good deal not that not the um um
you know not the big
touring cases right just the round hard
cases you bet oh yeah
yeah and they dw bought them
when when camco went out of business i
bought my second set in 72 i think
and added the the 18-inch floor tom to
the 16-inch floor tom
and they went out of business and then
dw bought them and they bought them just
for the connector
you know the tension rods on the drums
to hold the heads they bought them for
that engineering
and now all the dw drums have that round
yeah whatever hardware whatever you call
it yeah yeah i didn't know that
yeah people always talk about you know
you spend all these money on drums
everybody's like it's all this comes
from the same place and it's just like
all right we're going to have square you
you we're going to have the round ones
you're going to have that but it's all
kind of the same yeah the same wood or
whatever um
well
i got to tell you this i have such a um
respect for the band that that you were
in and um getting to know you
you know it's the greatest thing ever
like you're just such like the second i
feel like i've known you forever you're
just such a cool person to talk to
and uh i'd love to have you on again
just for whatever reason if you ever
just want to come on again and and talk
about like uh
you know the music scene back then or
whatever you're up to and you got to
come out to one of my shows whenever i'm
where are you at again
tucson
i'm in arizona next month
right before the new year somewhere in
phoenix
uh talking heads or something big venue
i don't know
that's about an hour if i could drive up
okay
huh are you worried i don't know
i'm doing a bit about a lesbian that
deliberately bumped into me so you might
not like me by the end of the show
[Laughter]
i don't have a problem with lesbian
jokes i really don't know no
yeah but i don't i don't do it in a
stupid way um
all right well listen f is for family
alex
from the great
fanny get behind fanny check out their
music is it available on itunes are they
giving you a half a cent for every
thousand downloads you got that
wonderful deal over there or you can go
to fannyrocks.com and buy them from me
from the actual drummer in the band
there you go
you had a freaking cd player instead of
oh i just use my phone i don't have a
computer i don't do anything it's just
everything's on the phone it's texting
it's this and that if you had a player i
would have sent them to you and you'd
know the whole catalog but no
well i have to follow the herd over the
cliff i i do have an external
you know what my wife has a boom box
around here somewhere
do you have a dvd player on your tv or
do you just my tv won't recognize that
old technology why can't you have
somebody you know in the neighborhood
turn it into an mp3 and send it to me
i could probably have byron do that but
i don't know if i could fit you know i'd
have to send it to you besides i don't
have your address i'm not sending brian
got a set gotta say okay
because here is the dude i will give you
an address to send them to
give me an address to send them to brian
calls me and he said
and this is two days before christmas
last year
and he said
you got a pencil and paper and i said
yeah
he says
okay write this down
so i wrote it down i said okay looks
like a phone number what is it he said
it's a phone number call it i said and
why am i who am i calling he says
it's bill burt's phone number and he
wants to talk to you
that's
i'm like you had to draw that out
because i told him if he could find out
from you
why fanny
i'd send him all the cds and he did and
i sent them he's got them all
that's amazing i just saw him we had we
had the f is for family we had the final
wrap party which was
so awesome but also you know sad because
i just i loved everybody on the show
and um
he was actually telling me like because
i'm trying to sell this movie script and
he was saying to me um
you know because i was going to bring
him on for it and i just saw him he
looked so happy i'm like look at you you
look great you drop some weight and all
that he goes yeah he goes i'm kind of
like semi-retired i don't know how long
i'm kind of retired
and i was like oh [ __ ] i was going to
see if you want to do this thing with me
and he's like well maybe i don't know i
was like dude you look too happy
i'm gonna
you can sit this one out he just looked
like
you know those people that just get out
of the rat race they start surfing or
they take some mushrooms something yes
he had that like he i'm stepping out of
the matrix
and i'm i'm liking it over here so um
which is something believe it or not
that i'm i'm trying to do you know i i
took some mushrooms earlier
this year and i've been stone sober ever
since
because of what i discovered on my
little mini trip i was like oh i need to
deal with that and i need to be sober to
do this so i haven't even even you know
i was sort of california sober as they
say i was still smoking weed or eating
an edible or whatever but i wasn't
you know doing anything else
now i've just been like
just sort of straight ever since then
and i've been thinking about maybe doing
one of those um
those therapeutic things because i heard
it's good for ptsd and stuff i think i
got a little bit of that from some
[ __ ] that happened to me and maybe i
could be a little easier to live with
than [ __ ]
uh you know maybe not look so
uncomfortable behind the drums
right i could well i can work on that
but
you got to get back to that island
yeah
that's where you got to go
oh well
yeah oh yeah what what the hell was the
name of that place i forget we stayed in
quincy
on this little little place out there
man it was it was awesome so uh yeah i
got to do that more often i also notice
when i start to really get like upset
and angry or whatever is i'm that just
means i need to stop
working so much
it's weird to say that out loud that's
so obvious but i'm just kind of like uh
i kind of like i don't know i just shut
down that's how your brain works
right yeah you just got to take care of
it that's all well well f is for family
just ended so i have a bunch of free
time so uh i'll have time to hang with
you down in phoenix
so i'd love to grab some lunch with you
or something like that and uh
send me your itinerary
hey maybe bring the cds up
maybe maybe i bring you something
whatever you i don't know what you're
looking you know we do a little surf and
turf see we'll see what's gonna happen
all right alex you're the best man you
are the best and thank you so much for
letting us use your music thank you for
your great music thank you for the band
fanny that then gave us the runaways the
go-gos the bangles and everybody after
that you guys are absolute legends and
you're a total rock star
i you just got that i don't give a [ __ ]
you'd still he said who gives a [ __ ]
about the rock and roll hall of fame i
mean right there you punk rock before
punk rock hey thanks thanks for giving
us the leg up on f is for family i can't
tell you how much it means to me i
understand
the whole
audience
growth potential right so it's yeah
all right
i'll be knocking on your doors for some
residuals
yeah okay
if the record company ever gives it to
you
they still say we owe them money can we
i know you know that we're not in profit
yet we took in two billion dollars we
spent three billion in advertising yeah
you still owe us a billion yeah it's
called hollywood math
all right alex if you're everybody from
fannie thank you so much for coming on
you're the best love you have a great
thanksgiving and i will see you next
month in phoenix
okay all right bye-bye everybody bye-bye
okay well that's the podcast everybody
but before we go
we have me and paul verzi's uh bet mgm
um
segment here where we talk about our
picks and all that
and uh
our little gambling thing there and
after that we'll have a bonus
um episode half hour episode of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcasts from uh greatest
hits one from uh
i don't know what thursday about a year
ago i don't know a couple years ago
however andrew does it all right thank
you guys
uh and enjoy the bettam gm
what's up everybody and we are back for
another nfl week 12 preview
okay sponsored by bet mgm here we go
guys we are back for week 12 of anything
better nfl preview with bet mgm season
we've been using bed mgm they have the
best most reliable lines out there uh to
make all your picks and we have special
offers for our listeners every week if
you haven't signed up to bet mgm yet use
bonus code bur that's burr couldn't be
more easy you'll get a hundred dollars
free after placing your first one dollar
bet here's how it works you go to bed
mgm you download the app you sign up
using bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r
okay place your first one dollar money
line bet nfl game that's it you'll
receive a hundred dollars in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use bonus code burr when you sign up
they're going to give you that free bet
they're going to give you that free
money could not be more easy people are
having a uh a great time with us and
what can i say about week 11
bill burr
does
i don't even know what we're gonna call
this the guy goes
unimaginable unforgivable and then gets
it all back with another unimaginable
and he goes four and oh again and i go
one and three cause the [ __ ] giants
stink i'm [ __ ] done we'll get into
that
congratulations billy now you got hey
it's feaster famine over here paul
feast of famine i'm either crushing it
or just hanging my head getting pelted
with snowballs
so you know
still a lot of time left paul
uh
yeah i'm left in the season that's why i
don't give a [ __ ] about the wreck and
you know i'm taking it one one week at a
time
we got seven months left but you've
turned you know i went to the right i
went to the raiders game
and i had uh i had joe burr
lsu great i had them uh
what was they they were laying one
you know raiders are in disarray i got
to tell you it's a shout out to all the
whole raiders organization they treated
me amazing treated me and raising but at
the end of the day paul i'm trying to
beat you here and gambling and i had to
go with what i thought
you know
so
what are you gonna do i'll tell you what
i'm excited paul i am as excited about
my new england patriots as you were
distraught about your packers but we'll
talk about that
at the on the uh the anything better
practice what we're here to do paul is
we're here to talk about gambling and i
understand there was a little bit of a
controversy with the monday night spare
shop
[Music]
put some money for you yes well i just
want to i want to address that a couple
of people on twitter some people saying
that uh i don't know what it was but we
what we said and if you listened was tom
brady throwing to daniel jones running
for one and some people i think there
was some confusion i apologize if
anybody was confused but if you listen
to it we listened back and that's what
it was and we had to take the under over
down uh just because it was
it wasn't registering right andrew was
that what happened
yeah for the most part
all right so
um anyway we'll be clear with all of the
moving forward but we we said rushing
and it will say when you look at the
monday night special when we do talk
about a quarterback throwing a when we
it will say throw touchdown you'll see
the word throw and if it says like
another quarterback one touchdown it
means rushing it'll say throw though to
to be clear um
but uh dude i think they're scared of us
over there at bet mgm that monday night
special we've been hitting that more
times lately and we've been coming close
and we've been coming close when we
didn't when we do miss we come close so
we got them on the edge of their seat
bill
we got it right where we want them got
them right where we want them um
i don't know what to say i'm going to
just say this i'm just going to say this
to to i just have to say this to vent
bill i i called bill last night i have
watched my new york football giants you
could see the sign on top of my door
okay
i have watched my new york football
giants i've been a fan since i'm eight
years old all right i have never
i have never seen a team allow an
offensive line okay
they ruined the last three years of eli
they're ruining this [ __ ] kid they're
ruining [ __ ] saquon barkley and and
on top of that we don't [ __ ] blitz
how am i a comedian i tell dick jokes
for a living in [ __ ] strip malls how
am i watching the game going why aren't
they blitzing why aren't they blitzing
why are they rushing four why is tom
brady look like he's in the backyard on
[ __ ] thanksgiving with his family
throwing the [ __ ] ball and i got the
[ __ ] announcer saying it everybody's
saying it that's how you beat tom brady
that's how you beat tom brady everybody
knows i tell you that's the only way you
beat him the only way you beat tom brady
in this [ __ ] game is you gotta knock
him on his ass and you gotta [ __ ]
make him think that's when he gets the
ball out that's when he makes mistakes
he's sitting back there the only thing
the guy didn't do is put a [ __ ] put
put [ __ ] tanning on his face and look
get a [ __ ] tan he could have sat
there so [ __ ] long
it was one of the most frustrating
things i'm [ __ ] done they gotta burn
it down fire everybody i'm [ __ ] done
dude it was ridiculous watching him sit
in the pocket that long our offensive
line stinks we have no defense i don't
even know what to say it's a [ __ ]
embarrassment it's an embarrassment it's
an embarrassment one of the best
franchises in the history of football
and we are [ __ ] digressing to the
[ __ ] cleveland browns right now
you're on the operational you're a
b-plus organization let's not get crazy
now let's not disrespect the cowboys the
steelers the 49ers and my new england
patriots
all right well we're top seven
organizations top eight history all
right okay
all right just take it down a little bit
it's
not do that new york thing where you
guys [ __ ] you guys always get a
little bump hitting off the ladies tees
because you got more buildings than
other people all right
end of the day paul no no as i'm gonna
do in new york i'm just saying we're a
team now if you count nfl titles you are
so i'm just [ __ ] with you no i know
but like we used to be a team especially
with eli on the road we used to be a
team that if we lose we're in the fight
we're in the game we're in the fourth
quarter we have a shot now it's like
it's a [ __ ] last night was a [ __ ]
joke man it was it was one of the most
frustrating things my wife was going
paul you got to stop yelling at the tv i
mean i [ __ ] you know i dude
if you want me to play your voice
message to me yeah go ahead play i mean
it was pretty much that i was [ __ ]
laughing my ass off not at you were just
cause i i've been there the [ __ ] is my
phone doing right now i haven't drank in
two weeks and i started drinking last
night during this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right here we go paul verzi put you
on speaker
oh wait wait
hang on a second it starts with dude you
watching this [ __ ] see if we can hear
this
oh sorry
i'm the [ __ ] worse
so are you watching this [ __ ]
can you hear me
you [ __ ] make him run for his life
and you put him in the ground that's how
the [ __ ] was super bowls that's how the
[ __ ] the washington [ __ ] football
team beat them last week okay we are
we're rushing [ __ ] four we're rushing
for these [ __ ] suckers don't want to
[ __ ] blitz you got all [ __ ] day it
looks like me playing in my backyard
with my [ __ ] kids i'm done with the
[ __ ] giants dude fire everybody bring
russell wilson to new york that's where
he wants to play anyway [ __ ] this dude
this i'm i'm watching this game and
these [ __ ] who aren't flexing
this guy
it's like what the [ __ ] are we doing
it's i'm sitting i can't [ __ ] believe
what i'm watching he's got all [ __ ]
day in the pocket dude i'm sick to my
[ __ ] son i don't even give a [ __ ]
about the game i'm just i'm i'm [ __ ]
living that my team
well i apologize for anybody if i uh
overly cursed i was a little really
upset last night i could tell you it
annoys me that russell wilson wants to
go to new york
well he doesn't like from what i heard
he's got a little beef with sneaky pete
he's not happy with sneaky pete and he
was in the yankees organization so i
think him doing that and meeting people
they always want to go to new york and
l.a
i want to be where all the media is
it's [ __ ] annoying
you made bad [ __ ] moves you should
have to pay for it nope new york and la
look at the [ __ ] lakers
goddamn [ __ ] expendables all came in
there
every [ __ ] action hero from the
2008's all-star game is in
just riding in like the [ __ ] calvary
it's annoying i love that that's not
working in la too i love that that
[ __ ]
five all hall of famers are like 500
right now i love it i never did remember
they tried to come on dude it's or this
is what always happens they'll go i
don't think they're on the same [ __ ]
page
lebron paces himself he knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing
he needles the team on twitter and then
they get going and they're gonna make a
[ __ ] run they always do they always
do with other people's [ __ ]
goddamn stars it's annoying if klay
thompson comes back nobody's beating
that warriors team dude the warriors are
[ __ ] where they lose three games they're
great dude they're well coached
everybody's healthy that makes me happy
yeah they're going to be good anybody
about the lakers unless the lakers draft
the [ __ ] team and add a couple people
i don't mind that [ __ ] but your whole
[ __ ] starting roster jesus [ __ ]
christ
and from the heels rockets and from the
[ __ ] oklahoma uh thunder we got
and coming out of retirement
all right paul you're you're still
looking at your bets this is why i'm
catching up with you you know you're
[ __ ] i'm looking at my bets i'm
trying to find andrews i'm trying to
find andrew's line so we could make our
week 12 picks here that's what i'm
saying i already got mine ready to go
all right well you go first again
because we missed one so you go first
all right i am gonna take i am gonna
take paul i hate i hate to tell you this
i'm taking the philadelphia eagles minus
three and a half at your football giants
you know i mean who watches him more
than you and after that [ __ ]
screaming and yelling
the eagles have been playing decent
they've been scoring [ __ ] points and
all that type of stuff
they're on the only thing i don't like
is it's a division rivalry but that
spread is close enough so i'm gonna go
with the eagles paul i'm taking the
eagles for the first time this year
uh they're on the up i am gonna go i'm
gonna go back
i'm gonna go back to the well here and
and and i'm gonna go with the san
francisco 49ers minus three at home
against the minnesota vikings uh san
francisco is clicking right now jimmy g
is the best uh quarterback in football
the last three weeks he's playing great
and i love the line being three i think
that that's a game that worst case
scenario i get a push i'm going with the
niners that are clicking right now i
think they're going to take a little
little ride to glory right now i think
they're going to go on a big run here so
i'm taking 40. i kind of like the
vikings in that game
just beating the packers i don't know
the 49ers have stunk just because you
play all of a sudden three games now i'm
supposed to believe they're a good team
i don't know
i don't know all right my next one um
jesus christ i'm gonna take the uh
packers
minus one at home versus the rams i
think it's gonna be cold out it'll slow
those [ __ ] down
and uh
you know packers floss last week
probably stinging you know aaron rodgers
is gonna come out and put a show on for
those people up there and in green bay
slash appleton wisconsin
okay
i'm going to take the pittsburgh
steelers get you [ __ ]
steelers getting four and a half
yeah i think [ __ ] bastard i wanted
that game i wanted the packers i should
have i wanted the packers oh you did
okay uh finally i take one from you
uh yeah i i just think that the steelers
have a the way that that game went last
week and they really can't lose another
one right now i think that their backs
against the wall i'm going to take them
division rival getting four and a half
against the basketball taking my
division rival
but i took your uh a good team coming
home on the road after a loss
ah
okay now now now now we separate the men
from the boys here
um
let's see here oh jesus what am i gonna
do here
i'm gonna go i hate i want to take the
patriots so bad i just don't like six
and a half
i don't like six and a half i know
travis tenry isn't in there i know the
titans just lost
to the [ __ ]
uh texans are the wheels coming off
are the wheels coming off [ __ ] it i'm
gonna take the patriots minus six and a
half
a lot of points i'll tell you it's a lot
of points paul
yeah but they're flying right now dude i
want to take the cowboys on thanksgiving
i like that
but i like that one they moved the line
though the line was seven and then they
just [ __ ] like [ __ ] made it seven
and a half which is just enough it's
just enough to bump you off the damn bet
but absolutely because if they're up
they're going to go into the [ __ ]
prevent if they're up by two scores and
they'll be up by 10 points and let them
walk down the field
i've been there paul that you know
here's my thing i don't unless i bet the
patriots i don't watch the games i bet
on it's great
for your uh you know
your sense of well-being
oh my god all right
you were so busy looking at your other
pick you didn't even listen right oh no
i heard i heard what you said oh my god
you don't like watching your your bets
and stuff i just go back and forth and
look uh
just gonna throw it out it's actually
derek henry uh you said travis travis
he's he's the old he's the old running
back yeah just to save everybody sorry
save everybody the comments
yeah oh maybe you should know the
[ __ ] running back
i got two kids under fourth and look as
long as i get one of the [ __ ] names
right i'm happy
oh my god it's between the bills and the
cowboys dude
the bill wants action on the holiday
yes
um
i'm gonna take the cowboys dude i'm
gonna take the cowboy seven and a half
the raiders aren't that good cowboys are
at home they're coming off of a loss
that's my theory i think that uh
they gotta put on a show there i know
they have if the half a point bites me
it bites me i'm taking the cowboys on
thanksgiving to win that game
raiders have a good front four but i
don't think they got enough
they got enough for the whole game um
all right
this is what i got left do i either go
falcons minus one at the jags or colts
getting two and a half at home against
the bucks
uh my thing is this time of year i do
not like to
i do not like to bet against tom brady
but [ __ ] carson wentz
is a point-scoring
son of a [ __ ]
that guy puts up points paul
yeah he puts up as a buck's defense i
don't [ __ ] know god damn it
um and the jags i don't know what their
deal is and i know what the falcons
you know what [ __ ] the falcons in the
jaguars they're two psycho chicks and i
never know what mood they're in so you
know what
i'm just gonna say to hell with it i'm
gonna go with the colts getting two and
a half at home against the bucks
i don't know i don't know about that
paul
this feels like a two and two week for
me at best well i think he's gonna make
up some games this week
my steelers i was feeling good about
that and if i had the steelers i could
you know take a little risk there with
the colts
listen the first half of you guys get
out of my comfort zone paul you got me
out of the pocket here the scrambler
the first half of the season was mine
but you've turned the ship around dude
so we're gonna have a nice fun little
run here at the end but i'm falling off
if i don't have a week this week
well you ever think maybe you were
overconfident i don't remember when it
was yours i had a couple of bad things
you you you told me i was ready to start
high-stepping it wasn't like [ __ ]
week five
you're the leon led of gamblers you
stuck the ball out you let don beebe
come running up behind you
uh i am up i don't know i'm up three and
a half games on you you have three and a
half games yeah i'm not even thinking
about high-stepping i'm like one bad
week he's right back in it that's what
happened last week paul
um
do i go bills
are the bills gonna [ __ ] beat the
saints by six points on thanksgiving
after they had it's up to six i thought
it was four and a half it's five and a
half now it moved up
ah
i'm going to take the bills of the
ravens man i go by what andrew sent us
this is the same it's the same link it's
just the better mgm like so if you
checked it last when did you check it
this morning
yeah it changed today it changed it must
have changed in between yeah well i'm i
am okay i have patriots six and a half
eagles three and a half and and colts is
cold still two and a half plus two yes
plus two and a half yeah yeah all right
so those those everything else is still
in yeah
all right
paul taking a
deep breath
uh i'm gonna take
oh my god this is tough dude i want to
take the the
it's the ravens of the bills and i don't
know which one to do but the ravens got
the ravens got the browns
and they're minus four and who the bills
bills have the saints yeah
i mean dude they they i mean unless the
first half of the season was [ __ ] i
mean aren't they due for something
breaking out here i love josh allen i
just don't somebody heard up there
there's something going on in the locker
room i just don't understand because i
don't haven't seen any major injury it
was like dude they were double-digit
um favorites the whole season were they
were i was riding them every week they
were covering
all right i'm going to do a curveball
right now are you ready for this one i'm
going to do a curveball
i'm going to take the detroit lions to
win their super bowl thanksgiving day
getting three points against the chicago
bears
they always play well on thanksgiving
the lot they're getting three wait this
is a this is their super bowl they
always play they always like they always
they [ __ ] lose every year on what are
you talking about
no they no i don't think they lose
everything i like the pick but i mean
let's not [ __ ] rewrite history paul
they were owen's 17 16 one year
yeah they i mean they're all nine and
one i mean it's as bad as it gets but
i'm taking their first i'm getting them
three points give it to me andrew i
didn't know they haven't won a game yet
this year good i like that that's good
karma let's get somebody into i love
detroit that's one of my favorite cities
let's get them a win paul paul versi
gets him a win
oh that's an early game that's 12 30.
that's 12 30
uh in two days ruin your dinner paul
i want to enjoy my holiday i stayed away
from both of those they don't need dad
degenerate dad's screaming at the tv the
lions are a bit below 500 overall uh
i don't know when this article is
written let me double check
that goes back to bobby lane 23 hours
ago yeah 37 42 and 2. two ties came on a
three-year span from 63 to 65. from 51
to 63 they played the packers every
thanksgiving overall
if anybody's listening to this from
detroit what is the furthest detroit has
ever gotten in the playoffs ever in
their history i want to know that like
around
as far as super bowl era i remember
eddie murray hitting a
field goal against the 49ers or
something
baseball player
uh he was also a kicker okay i believe
i believe that was his name let me look
it up i probably [ __ ] that one up too
you see him with an orioles hat kick it
no he's right eddie murray
bam okay m-u-r-r-a-y
there you go look at that huh you're all
everybody was all ready to get all sore
at me yeah
all right
all right everybody that's the pics
that's the picks for our uh week 12 a
preview
um
bill has a three and a half game lead we
want everybody to have a happy uh you
got to have a 4-0 in you
what 17 weeks you got to get a 4-0 got
i've had a bunch of three ones i've
never gotten it though this ride's made
never a bride paul it's gotta happen we
get it we'll get it this year hopefully
instead of the monday night special do
you want to do the sunday night special
that'll be the cleveland browns versus
the ravens division rivalry uh or it's
monday's game is seattle washington so
it's up to you guys
i like cleveland ravens i like that
division it's a little more fun of a
game yeah yeah so it's a sunday night
sunday night don't get it confused guys
it's the sunday night special
let the sunday night special all right
so we'll do we'll do the sunday night
special will be minus four ravens at
home against the browns you guys want to
do lamar jackson rushing 50 yards
i need a four in that paul
i'm i'm seeing 45.
45 yards 45 yards okay lamar jackson
rushes for 45 yards
go ahead bill what do you want what do
you got in there baker mayfield throws a
pick
oh i love it
love that
all right he scrambles he tries to make
things happen
i think you know
i just feel like they need a win he
might he might
force one in there but i'm a big baker
mayfield fan
um but i just feel like there's gonna be
one of those it's going to be one of
those uh
so that means uh what else we need one
more thing here
i like the ravens at home i think
they're a better football team i like
titans minus four
is he going to go in there and break
their hearts paul
no
you don't think so baker mayfield
doesn't come in there and ruin their
thanksgiving weekend
i don't think so
yeah ravens always have a defense yeah i
like that let's go let's go defense good
quarterback good kicker a good coach um
great seafood
you know great crab cakes yeah
um all right
so just so people are clear and nobody's
confused lamar jackson rushing for over
45 yards or 45 yards or more and with
the money line we're taking the ravens
minus four okay
and that's the sunday night special
sunday night special is done week 12
preview is done if you guys are in
connecticut thanksgiving weekend i'm
going to be at the stress factory in
bridgeport connecticut november 26th two
shows november 27th two shows come out
i'm doing the new hour and it is my last
weekend of the year all right here we go
i don't even have to read it i know it
guys go to the best damn app there is in
all of gaming it's the bet mgm app use
bonus code bur
b-u-r-r and they will match uh your
first bet dollar bet uh a hundred bucks
right andrew is that it
yes so it's very simple just go go to
the bet mg download the bet mgm app use
bonus code burr b-u-r-r
and your first dollar bet they will give
you a hundred dollars on your first bet
come enjoy it have a good time it's the
best reliable uh
uh gambling app out there and uh that is
it everybody use bonus code b-u-r-r come
join us we'll see you guys next week you
have to be 21 years of age or older to
wager in arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan minnesota new
jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
uh new customer offer paid in free bets
visit bet mgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for arizona uh 800 522 4700
for colorado dc nevada wyoming and
virginia
800-270-717 for confidential help
michigan 1-800 gambler indianapolis new
jersey pennsylvania west virginia 1-800
bets off for iowa call or text the
tennessee red line 800-889-9789
minnesota
uh sports betting is a void in georgia
hawaii ohio and utah and other states uh
were prohibited uh promotional offers
not available in nevada and now enjoy
the bonus
episode um
of a greatest hits throwback just before
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast hey what's going
on it's bill burr and it's the monday
morning podcast for monday
november 25th
2013 how you doing
how are you
happy thanksgiving
eat some turkey and some stuffing and
gravy
and then eat some pie
i love thanksgiving
i really do but you know i'm actually uh
i'm leaving the country
i'm gonna be an expatriate now i'm
leaving the country um the wednesday
before thanksgiving i didn't even
realize that this is going to be the
first thanksgiving i ever spend
you know
outside of the country i'm actually
going to be over in italy
like like like one of the some of the
army guys back in the day in world war
ii
sitting over there when the moon itch
here i like a big pizza pie shoot him in
the face
um
getting ready for my big european tour
over there everybody you know i didn't
realize when when we went to book this
thing how [ __ ] cold it was gonna be
in scandinavia in december and i just
did some uh some interviews there
for the uh norwegian journal or the
[ __ ] swedish uh
uh periodical whatever the [ __ ] whoever
i was talking to over there and um they
told me they were laughing that i was
coming over there like why are you
coming over here now which is never a
good sign
you know when the people
you know of the nation are not open like
are not welcoming you with open arms
they're immediately going like yeah you
sure you want to do
this i guess the sun goes down at three
in the afternoon
i can't belie it's like is it that far
[ __ ] north
and i'm starting to think about i'm like
wait a minute if he goes straight across
from massachusetts where i grew up where
do you end up mediterranean sea
the south of spain i okay i don't even
[ __ ] know and then i'm thinking like
wait a minute they've
wait a minute they're way the [ __ ] up
there they're like yukon territories
they're that high up
you know because you look at a [ __ ]
map it's flat
you spin a globe you can't see it it's
around the corner where is it where is
you know
am i supposed to take a string i didn't
[ __ ] know so evidently it's gonna the
sun's gonna go down at three
then it's gonna be cold as hell
i don't give a [ __ ] it's still gonna be
a good time
you know break up my party
um
you know what's funny though is i talked
to this person in iceland
the radio show and they said okay before
we start this i got to do the uh
i gotta you know they were
recording it for the radio and he goes
all right before
uh i ask you the questions i just have
to do a quick
um intro so i'm like this this this is
always cool because they speak in their
native tongue and then they go right
back to you and i've never heard the
icelandic
language
and it's [ __ ] cool as hell you know
what it sounds like remember when they
would play lyrics backwards that devil
[ __ ]
on on metal records that's what it
sounded like he's like okay i'm going to
do the intro but i can't do i can't even
do the accent then he just goes russia
oh my god
i hope these [ __ ] people are gonna be
bilingual because there's no way i could
ever make
like that you know there's certain
languages that i feel like i could make
like spanish i know
if i could just find some beautiful
spanish woman
to teach me
mexican latino whatever the [ __ ] i'm
supposed to say if you just come over
here with your brown titties hanging out
of your [ __ ] beautiful white blouse
you know
i could learn the damn language
all right if i could get some french
woman
dress up like one of those hoary babes
i would have it down
the problem is as i sit here with this
rosetta stone and i'm talking to a
[ __ ] computer
where
is
the motivation
the second i walk away from the computer
i can immediately speak english and do
anything
i want
i can get food
i go to africa i go to asia i can do
whatever i want
um why don't i just think of that weird
girl in uh breakfast club
um
i don't know if that was the the proper
quote
anyways back to what the [ __ ] i was
talking about so like the motivation
isn't there so what i think i'm gonna do
this next time i try rosetta stone
to learn spanish french whatever the
[ __ ] i'm trying is i'm just gonna have
beautiful women
like pictures of them on the wall
even then what's that gonna do
you know what they should have they
should just start
like you know like they have like those
those late at night
talk to some hottie
and they just show these ridiculously
hot women like yeah hey
for some reason nobody's buying me a
bunch of stuff tonight i'm just sitting
here with my panties on why don't you
call me up and talk to me you zitted
back fat [ __ ] right
any
you know it isn't true but you want to
believe it so
this might be a good business and i
don't want to start a [ __ ] business
all right i have no so
feel free to steal this idea
what you do is you hire a bunch of
hotties
to skype
with people to teach them the language
of their nation
nah that wouldn't work
because the amount of times that they
would click to talk to somebody and all
they would see is just some dick getting
[ __ ] stroked
that would just be really traumatic for
those beautiful women and why would you
want to do that
you know if they were nice enough
if they were nice enough to like
take time from being hot to teach
somebody a different language they're
probably a good person
so they shouldn't be subjected to that
all those other [ __ ] that are just
walking around being hot for hot sake
for the sake of being hot and getting a
free jello shot
you know i wouldn't have a problem with
them having some video dick
like shook in their faces
does that make sense i'm unbelievably
[ __ ] jet-lagged everybody speaking of
smart people i i did a college gig
at this theater
and uh and i literally flew out and came
right back so i don't even know the name
of it
i have no idea it's the second time i've
been there and i want to shoot a special
there the crowd was [ __ ] awesome
there
okay i showed you my respect but um
i went there because me and verzi went
to the harvard yale game at the yale
bowl the original bowl
in the united states of america this is
the one that started all of it the
reason why there is the rose bowl that i
go to every [ __ ] year
uh is because of the yale bull
and we went there and i gotta tell you
we saw what sports look like
without the um use of any sort of
steroids
[Laughter]
versey was [ __ ] hilarious
he was going bill i'm not even joking
i feel that if i went to this school and
i played for yale like i could not only
make the football team i could like
dominate like i could stand out and i
understood why he felt that way i'm not
saying he's right but to sit in the
stands
and for the first time
in my life
be watching college football and seeing
people that are kind of the same size as
you i know they're way [ __ ] faster
and all that type of thing but um
it was unbelievable yale versus harvard
harvard kicked the [ __ ] out of him
and uh i got to tell you like it was it
was really cool just being around that
many smart people
looks like some 20 year old fat kid
walking through the crowd wearing like a
bow tie
like not like a clip-on like you tie it
yourself like he knows how to do it it's
just immediately it's like how [ __ ]
smart is that guy
like who knows how who [ __ ] knows how
to do that
i'll tell you smart people and
plantation owners are the only ones who
know how to do that [ __ ] bow tie
right
and then there was some really good
looking women there and they were they
were you know that was just that's a
really turn on to see women that good
looking
you know
and they're actually going to harvard
they're just not walking around being
hot getting free [ __ ] they're actually
doing something with your life that's
really a turn-on can you imagine banging
a girl like that
just being on top of her like oh god
she's so smart
she has all the answers
um
i know this is ridiculous so the yale
bowl everybody
in case you're wondering the yale bowl
is a football stadium in gun wave in new
haven connecticut um on the border of
west haven
yada yada yada yada it was constructed
and broke ground in 1913.
all right cost him 750 grand 17.5
million in today's dollars
that was the 130th meeting
between yale and harvard and i was just
sitting there thinking like george bush
george w used to get [ __ ] shit-faced
back when he was still a good [ __ ]
drinking
you know he used to get hammered here
hillary [ __ ] blew bill clinton
under the bleachers
right
now those those two families uh they're
the worst i don't mind his dad
but [ __ ] georgie jr and the clintons
they're just the [ __ ] worst but
anyways um
basically ground was broken in 1913
and it was the first bull shaped stadium
in the country and provided inspiration
for the
the design of such stadiums as the los
angeles memorial coliseum the rose bowl
and michigan stadium this was the one
that started it all this is the daddy to
the granddaddy of them all
all right this is zeus
to all the athenas and mercuries and all
that [ __ ] did i jump between greek and
roman gods i don't give a [ __ ]
all right you goddamn egghead why don't
you go tie your bow tie again today
nobody gives a [ __ ]
um so we went there and dude verzi was
so [ __ ] first of all he killed on the
show and then
he was staying at this hotel
and before the show uh
we were hanging and uh in my hotel room
we were watching lsu playing uh the
aggies
and i was great to see lsu win you know
after all the disappointing losses this
year and uh
when you looked out the window you could
see yale's campus
and i was joking with paul and i was
going look at it paul
i go it's so close and then i point it
to my brain and i'm like yet so far away
and i'm laughing and first he's such
like a [ __ ] competitive
psycho
he starts going dude [ __ ] that
dude [ __ ] these [ __ ] people you he's
like you think we couldn't get into
school i'm like yeah
yeah i don't think we didn't paul
you know you're gonna go into
fantasyland what happened is we both
went to high school
and we tried
and we didn't get in so yeah
this this isn't even like a debate at
this point we didn't and now we're
coming back here like a couple of
[ __ ] dancing monkeys
to entertain these people
all right
and he he wouldn't he wouldn't leave it
alone he just kept going like dude [ __ ]
that if i had a better upbringing you
know if i had like people who like
made me focus on academics
and if i yeah paul yeah if you're not
the result of of morons [ __ ]
right
that's too harsh
um
i feel like i'm the same way all right
jesus christ they just attacked his
parents that's that you know that's the
last thing i want to do on this podcast
but verzi's sitting there he would
was not joking
saying that he could be he could make it
he could have went to yale and that's
why i love that guy
is i just sit there and look and go
there's no [ __ ] way he's yeah
we can do it
it's there's no [ __ ] fursy if you're
listening to this there is no [ __ ]
way
if your parents made you read books
every goddamn like there's no [ __ ]
you've said enough dumb [ __ ] to me
the foundation of you
it's just not there the same as me paul
okay it's it's built on it's built in
sand
um now
had either one of our parents gone there
and then we were part of a legacy or
whatever the [ __ ] they call it we go i
could go there i could go to yale the
way george w went there
you know
get there have that [ __ ] look on my
face
just getting shit-faced everybody loving
me
hey he's a complete fuck-up he has no
business being here but he got he bought
the keg
right i'd be that guy
i don't [ __ ] know either way we went
to the game
and uh
it was great it was really like uh was
sort of pure
there was nothing riding on the game
there's no reason to play football at
yale and harvard
other than you love playing football and
then also the fact that you know they're
all really smart
that was something really fascinating
about it like that guy look at that guy
out there he gets geometry
and he just went over the middle and
took that hit that's just [ __ ]
amazing to me
just multi-talented so
i got all kinds of respect i got to tell
you i think harvard was on the juice
though beca or they have some sort of
i don't know
lock on draft picks because they see
there seemed to be a definite
a sizable difference between the
athletes on harvard side versus uh yale
and i didn't know who to root for
i liked yale's colors but harvard's from
massachusetts
all right i'm done with this [ __ ] um all
right back to the [ __ ] podcast
so oh i have an announcement to make
everybody
after threatening forever
that there would be podcast t-shirts
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
boys and girls of all sizes sizes and
sizes
the podcast t-shirts are here
t-shirt info
they are available as of right now
monday morning
they come in gray and white
sizes small medium large
extra
large and double extra-large
t-shirts are 20 bucks in the united
states
25 for foreigners
um dvds are also 20 bucks 25 for uh
international you can buy them together
and save t-shirt and dvd combo is 30
bucks u.s 35 international and i got to
tell you man that makes a great gift as
i say every year it's a great
[ __ ] gift
just for somebody that you don't give a
[ __ ] about but you got to get him you
gotta get him something right get him a
dvd here you go go [ __ ] yourself laugh
it up [ __ ] oh right
who doesn't like a t-shirt
all right these are those amp now what
is it well
not amber crombie and fitch who's the
guy who takes the creepy pictures of
teenagers
it begins with an a
you know you know the deal you know the
[ __ ] they are ah [ __ ]
whatever they're nice and soft
this is really bad just after he's
saying he takes pictures of teenagers he
has those creepy things it's not calvin
klein
he's like the new calvin klein
you know what i'm saying they're [ __ ]
great t-shirts all right and um this is
also a good thing too you know
brother
father anything for guys a goddamn
t-shirt and a dvd my [ __ ] comedy
they're gonna love it it's a perfect
thing the lovely nina everybody
hello coming into the room
you got i gotta sign what here
jesus she comes in here
with a goddamn blank check and tells me
i just have to sign it do you understand
the faith i'm putting in you right now
you don't be hilarious as if you just
cleaned me out right now and i never saw
you again
i would never do that huh i would never
do that you sound like you sound like
sharon stone right now in that
basic instinct that'd be pretty crazy
write a [ __ ] something something all
right see you
um
have a nice day with my money
i'm jump [ __ ] with you come here
that's me always make taking the joke
one one [ __ ] step too far
why did you have to say that now people
are gonna think they're not you're
[ __ ] saint for being with me
all right
so there you go t-shirt info
you got it it's up there holidays are
coming if you order now
all right there's no [ __ ] way you're
not gonna get it before christmas i
guarantee it
if you don't get it before christmas i
will show up at your christmas party in
2018 doing a tap dance with the [ __ ]
two two one that's a guarantee
i'm really betting that you're not gonna
remember that it's gonna [ __ ] get
there is all i'm saying and no i'm not
doing your christmas party all right
don't be so goddamn selfish i gotta
humiliate myself don't i do that every
week when i read the advertising
speaking of which
yeah i think it's time for a little bit
of advertising everybody here we go
um i'm in danger right now of not making
the cut
on the tour here
all right
now
let's try to make me make it easier
we'll say that
par for the course is three fuck-ups in
these reads
all right
all i want to do is make part now i want
to be one under
i want to come into the clubhouse with a
smile on my face all right here we go
dollar shave club everyone for a couple
of bucks a month dollar
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door not
only does it save you a ton of cash it
saves you from trudging to the drugstore
for a pack of blades all right i always
get stuck behind that old couple that
wants to buy ice cream and develop their
photos as they sit there sharing a pair
of loaf loafers
one one stroke against me damn it but
now with dollar shave club for just a
couple bucks a month amazing quality
razor blades are delivered right to your
door that's right no more wasting time
and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks
every time you go to buy razors
everybody here is getting their dollar
shave club blades and you should too
everybody here meaning me and here's a
genius idea try replacing your old
shaving cream with dr cavi's
easy shave butter
from
dollarshaveclub.com trust me your face
will thank you later don't waste time at
the drugstore behind the lady paying in
pennies go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high save time save money go to
dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash burr
that was one under
i only had one i was too under for that
one
oh my god look what's back everybody
look what's back just in time for the
holiday season
dooby dooby doo
and scootally bop get a [ __ ] man
great and throw it at your daddy's head
man great everybody
bill burn man great copy for christmas
2013. i don't think that that was part
supposed to be part of the read here all
right now it starts that was just a
couple of practice
swings off the tee
all right this holiday
can i have a mulligan this holiday
season think the man great
what is the man great you ask or maybe
you didn't ask maybe i'm putting words
in your mouth because i know what's good
for you
they're 100 made in america cast iron
grilling grates that are revolutionizing
the way people grill named one of 2012's
best grilling accessories by men's
health magazine
you like that grilling men's health is
there enough dicks in that story for you
that you know this is a good product
they're the perfect gift for this
holiday season click on the man great
banner on billboard.com for their 1999
holiday special
you can thank your father for bringing
you into the world for less than twenty
dollars
and every time he goes to eat a steak
he's gonna call you up
you know
thank you son
god bless you for 19.99 you can have
that conversation remember each monday
morning podcast order comes with a heavy
duty grilling brush again that's the man
great grill enhancement system order
today at billberg.com or you my friend
are an [ __ ]
all right one more hulu plus
you've probably tried hulu.com now with
hulu plus you can watch your favorite
shows anytime anywhere hulu plus lets
you watch thousands of hit tv shows and
a selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet and it all streams
in hd for the best viewing experience
with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite current tv shows like saturday
night live
community and family guy do you know
what's actually just called saturday
night
because they had howard cosell actually
hosted
a saturday night live or something like
that so they weren't allowed to say it
that's why they say live from new york
it's saturday night just to give you
that little tidbit of information i
learned that the other day reading an
actual book about howard coself
why would i read about other things
because i'm a [ __ ] anyways back to hulu
plus you can always check out exclusive
content including hulu originals like
the awesome starring snl's seth meyers
or sn's seth meyers and moon boys
starring chris o'dowd from bridesmaids
hulu plus also offers a great selection
of acclaimed films
for only 7.99 a month you can stream as
many tv shows and movies as you want
wherever you want right now you can try
hulu plus free for two weeks when you go
to huluplus.com bill that's a special
offer from my listeners make sure you
use the huluplus.com bill so you get an
extended free trial and they know that
we sent you go to huluplus.com bill now
or click the hulu plus banner at on the
podcast page at billbird.com
it i was doing great and i came up the
18th [ __ ] fairway and i shanked in
the goddamn woods all right back to the
podcast here all right
very uneventful week i feel everybody
so uh considering there's not a lot
going on in the world
of politics
what should we talk about oh i don't
know hey let's talk about sports
anybody watch any sports this weekend
were you were you were you watching
things that involve sports
was there sports watching
um
all right first things first i have to
address the uh
the no call pass interference thing last
week
in the panthers game um
that was obviously a monday night game
so i didn't comment on it uh i didn't
have a problem with it
i thought it was a good no call i didn't
like that they threw the flag and then
picked it up but
how's gronk gonna make a [ __ ] play on
a pass that's not even gonna get to him
it's not like the guy who interfered
with him or held him
caught the ball it was another guy who
undercut the route
and
i just feel like the rules
in the nfl right now are tipped so
heavily in favor of the offense it's
nice every once in a while to see the
defense get a break even if it goes
against my [ __ ] team
okay
classic examples if you watch the giants
cowboys game
early in that game
i think the cowboys were up seven or
nothing at that point
they forced the fumble they recovered it
and away from the play there was a flag
where the cornerback barely grazed this
wide receiver and negated
the cowboys you know turnover the
defense made a play caused the turnover
once again made a play caused the
[ __ ] turnover and in this this new
the new rules i mean i can't complain
they are the rules
negates that and and stops them from
having a short field and possibly going
up 14 to nothing or 21 nothing i can't
remember watch so i did not have a
problem with it
good for the panthers and i actually
tweeted that i didn't have a problem
with it and i got all these [ __ ]
condescending
yeah
like responses to it like oh it's good
to see a level-headed
patriots fan it's good to see an
impartial patriots fan it's good to see
a smart patriots fan what because i
[ __ ] agree with you and your team you
selfish [ __ ]
you know right there that's when you
know like you don't have a true friend
is when they just like you because you
agree with them
and i would i am i would be willing to
bet a most of my [ __ ]
whatever
my shillings here
that those people who compliment me are
not impartial and had the call gone if
the exact same [ __ ] thing happened to
their
um their receiver and they lost the game
they would be [ __ ] moaning and
complaining and saying how tom brady
runs the league and all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right so before you sit there
and try and pat me on the head
and say that i am impartial and i'm a
smart patriots fan that's not a [ __ ]
compliment all right you're a [ __ ]
all right as long as i agree with you
and your team and i don't agree with my
team and it causes you to have a victory
then then i'm smart go [ __ ] yourself
um and with that we get to uh yesterday
yesterday's games the uh new york
football giants
lost and i know a lot of people think
that i hate the giants because uh
they beat the patriots two times in a
row in super bowls i don't not only do i
not hate the giants i love the giants i
love that organization i've liked them
for for [ __ ] ever
all the way back to harry kassen brad
van pelt beasley reese i've been
watching them forever i've always liked
the giants i like the uniforms i like
the the the
defenses i just liked them
there's nothing better than having like
two when they had lawrence taylor and
harry carson
and you know i was like wilbur marshall
i was always like big linebacker like i
like the bears
i like defenses and that type of thing
so i don't hate the giants
what i hate is listening to paul versi
talking about how he called something
because he doesn't just say it for that
weekend he'll say it for the next seven
years so the reason why i wanted to see
the giants lose
is because i don't want to listen to
versi
talking to me like he's nostradamus if
that's how you pronounce that guy's name
um
so that's all
and what kills me too is that division
is so bad that they're still they're
still not out of it they're only two
games out of first place
three from going all the way up front
which should be insurmountable after 10
[ __ ] games but with that division it
isn't
it isn't all right
i don't know who shot i don't know who's
not waiting what are they are they are
they four and seven
oh so it's 11 games oh yeah they're
pretty much [ __ ]
um but i was i got to tell you in the
back of my head i was kind of hoping
that they were going to make it
be into the playoffs because playoffs
because i have a feeling
just the way the giants are they
they would beat
seattle in seattle
another bunch of people would probably
think
that i hate the seattle seahawks because
i did that whole you know the we are the
loudest song and i always make fun of
pete carroll i don't hate him i don't
give a [ __ ] about the seahawks
one way or the other i think the loudest
crowd thing is silly
and it's something that you focus on
when you don't have any championship
banners to look at and i stand by that
but that doesn't mean i want you to lose
but pete carroll
it's just funny watching that guy lose
you know watching a guy who goes
when something good happens and he's
totally proven himself as a coach he's a
great [ __ ] coach he's a great college
coach
he knows how to build up the program
illegally and right before the all the
[ __ ] hits the fan
to walk away from it and i don't
begrudge him for doing that because
that's how the game's played the same
way i don't begrudge lance
for for doing what the [ __ ] he did when
everyone else was doing it
i don't begrudge any of that and
everybody who gives the patriots [ __ ]
for the spygate thing is living in this
fantasy [ __ ] land that your teams do
not cheat
i'm reading this great book right now on
uh
uh i don't have the title of it i'll
i'll get it for you next week lawhead
gave me the book
uh some of the last headbangers or
something like that it's like basically
back when you just played with
concussions and that type of [ __ ] the
level of cheating that was going on
first of all they didn't even test for
steroids i think until like 1988 in
football
and if you read about the oakland
raiders who still to this day [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] tuck rule
um
the [ __ ] they were doing in the 70s
dude do you know like they used to have
like their pads they used to soak them
in water because it would make them hard
and it was almost like having like a
cast on and they would just club people
in the head and other teams knew that
they were doing it so during the
pre-games and the warm-ups they would
wear the soft ones
and they'd have their hard ones under
the bench and there wasn't nine zillion
[ __ ] tv cameras and people in the
crowd all having tv cameras with their
smartphones so when the game started
they would put the other pads on they
would just clock people in [ __ ] head
these guys were claiming they were
taking horse tranquilizers and they were
doing the dosage for a [ __ ]
1500 1200 pound [ __ ] horse
um they were out of their minds hopped
up on everything in the plant so people
have cheated
all day long and the greatest thing
about cheating is watching people who
don't cheat discover that there's
cheating and to just watch them as
adults once again discovered that
there's no santa claus and seeing their
bottom lip quiver i just for the life of
me the reason why it's funny is not
because i condone cheating it's just
that
i just don't i don't [ __ ] get
it's like how many times you got to get
[ __ ] over to realize that
how human beings are
you know i'm a piece of [ __ ]
right
why wouldn't a football team when
there's a zillion dollars at stake
and and your legacy and your your spot
on the all-time
list
i'm not saying everybody's gonna cheat
but i just get this [ __ ] shocked look
off your face
like when oj got acquitted oh my god
that millionaire the guy who had the
money enough to be innocent gets
declared in this yes
all right am i [ __ ] am i like
preaching right now i should shut the
[ __ ] up oh and then also
what was i gonna say uh
how unreal was that but that
patriots broncos game i guess it's
unreal if you're on the [ __ ] winning
side or if you didn't give a [ __ ] who
won or not
um
unreal i watched that
game
flying i was on virgin airlines
who by the way
they have this five-minute music video
for as great as that airline is when you
get on that
plane rather than have them announce
like this is how you put on a seat belt
and a mask which usually takes
live human beings like a minute they
made like a five minute video
that tries to have all the like people
dancing and singing and and auto-tuned
voices and i gotta tell you it is one of
the most horrific things
i've ever heard and it's played at such
a volume i had my fingers in my ears and
i was humming and i could still hear it
i heard it on the way out and the way on
the way back i just gave into it and i
just watched it
and um
i don't you know you don't really annoys
the [ __ ] out of me is people who dance
with an attitude look on their face
like they think that they're [ __ ]
amazing like
i'm not saying that i don't respect the
art of dancing
but
what is with that look on your face
you know like your [ __ ] gronkowski
and you just dragged [ __ ] the entire
secondary over the goal line
what are you doing what because you did
a little shim sham
huh
because you're shaking your left
shoulder while your right toe is doing
something else like now you have this
look on your face
like you're lining up across and you're
reading the defense what is the what is
with that [ __ ] look
people have on their faces when they
dance now
did fred astaire have that look on his
face
when you're dancing there's only one
look you should have on your face
and it should convey roughly
all right stop looking at me like you're
gonna take my wallet
i i just don't [ __ ] understand five
minutes of that
combined
with like auto tune
and that [ __ ] robot dancing that i i
i just don't with this [ __ ] look of
attitude and then rapping they got some
little girl
[Music]
[ __ ] rapping like sounding like dice
when he makes fun of women
about how to put a seat belt on and it
goes on for like five minutes as you sit
underneath these aquarium jizz lights
the same ones that they have at the w
hotel
um
other than that it's great because you
get to just sit there and watch tv so
anyways
when i got through the whole [ __ ] uh
put on your seatbelts and rock and roll
whatever the [ __ ] they were singing
oh just wouldn't [ __ ] end so
um
i actually i i was watching the patriot
i watched all the giants game
and then i went into the went into the
patriots game right before we were about
to make it 24-21 got off the plane and
somehow it was already 24-21 and i
went by the bar and i saw a score to
make it 28-24
that's all right 24-21 and then 28-24
and um
it was in state and then the whole way
back from the airport version was
texting me the updates and right as i
got home
i saw the replay of the uh
of the punt
well the guy inadvertently touched it
because he didn't hear welker tell him
to get out of the way but uh
what a [ __ ] game
and um
yet another reason why you don't leave
early
but i don't think that that was a
definitive
example of what brady and manning can do
because i thought the elements played
such a [ __ ] role
in the game but i will say this brady is
ten in four in 14 matchups against
peyton manning so
i am done with that argument
all right if you want manning go ahead
you can you can have them
i will take brady
any day all day
you know
brady doesn't even have that look on his
face
neither does peyton manning that these
[ __ ] dancers have as they're trying
to tell me how to put on a [ __ ] seat
belt
did people who like dance did they just
get sick of getting beat up so now they
feel like they have to take it on and
now they have to have a game face
um
[Laughter]
i was just watching it like when did
kevin garnett start dancing i don't
understand oh that's not kevin garnett
that's just somebody dancing
um
i'm so exhausted from watching that
whole [ __ ] game and traveling around
i don't i don't know what to say i'm not
gonna try to rub anybody's nose and
anything it was at the end of the day an
unbelievable win and just a regular
season [ __ ] victory and uh
but it was um
it definitely
if you watch that game and you still
leave games earlier you're not a sport
you leave the game early you're not a
[ __ ] sports fan i just
was watching people clear out i
understood because it was [ __ ]
freezing and you're down 24 nothing i
understand if you're down 24 nothing at
the half and it's [ __ ] like
absolutely freezing
disgusting and you're with your little
boy or your girl and they're cold they
want to go back to the car i get that
all right but if you're a [ __ ] man
and you're standing there in the [ __ ]
stands for the love of god
all right the offensive lineman can be
out there in short sleeve shirts
you know you can't tough it out in your
mighty mac with your [ __ ] mittens
and they leave
and they watch one of the historical
comebacks
in new england sports
title town
it's just an unbelievable run every time
you think you've seen the last great
thing that's going to happen and then
it's going to go back to the way it was
another great thing happened so i feel
very blessed as a sports fan so well
there you go
there you go great [ __ ] game and this
is the thing too i don't think as much
as that was a big win that doesn't mean
[ __ ]
when the playoffs come
because we're gonna have to go into
denver and at the end of the day to use
that overly used expression denver could
come back and beat us
in january and then who gives a [ __ ]
that we beat him in in november despite
the fact that it was an unbelievable
victory
um i mean [ __ ]
that happened with the jets we
absolutely raped the jets in december
and then a month later we lost to him at
home so who gives a [ __ ] um
they're both great quarterbacks
and they're both great teams and who
gives a [ __ ] it was an amazing goddamn
game i can't believe we came back and
won it and uh i'm done arguing the brady
manning thing
i think the numbers speak for themselves
as far as the way i look at the numbers
and uh
i think they both played each other
enough times
with all different kinds of teams loaded
teams
patch together teams like our [ __ ]
defense last night i'm so [ __ ] sick
of them too talking about how many
injuries we have on defense and then
they're going like they absolutely just
just ran right through the guts of that
patriots defense it's like oh yeah the
one word yeah where the guts were
already ripped out there's no guts left
in it
well there are because we won the game
i'm not saying that people are out there
do we started four rookies yesterday
i i just
you're gonna have a guy as good as
[ __ ] no sean running the ball yeah
he's gonna rack up some [ __ ] yards
although over 200 is inexcusable so
whatever all right let's uh let's get on
to the uh the questions this week see i
think i handled that really well
i hope you i don't rub your [ __ ]
noses
in it unless you're jets fans
um all right response to last podcast or
yankee fence
response to last podcast uh this is in
response to the item mentioned on your
last podcast the brother that had the 16
year old sister who was dating a 22 year
old
okay all capital letters
this guy writes the brother needs to
stay out of it all right so for those of
you who didn't uh listen last week there
was a guy whose 16 year old sister was
dating this 22 year old dude and he was
questioning do i knock this guy the [ __ ]
out do i say something to my sister do i
somehow get my parents to wake the [ __ ]
up what do i do
all right i gave my advice and this guy
is saying this he seems like he's
speaking from experience or this woman
whoever wrote this the brother needs to
stay out of it
i meant oh it's a lady i met my now
husband
when i was 15 and he was 20.
well you little fast [ __ ]
you couldn't even drive a car how did
you even meet a 20 year old huh
well you standing on the street corner
why
[Music]
i'm sure you're a nice person
sorry
um
you were 15 and he was 20.
did your plane crash and he was stuck on
an island
and it was like that blue lagoon or some
[ __ ] he said we started dating just
after i turned 16.
and we got married when i was 20 and he
was 25.
we have now been happily married almost
25 years oh that's a nice story it may
not work out this way for this guy's
sister but it also might work out too
and end up being a stronger relationship
than any relationship this guy might
have it's none of the brothers business
stay out of it
okay
miss i respect
your point of view and what happened to
you all right but let me ask you this
if you have a daughter and she turns 16
and some 22 year old guy starts sniffing
around the house are you gonna just sit
there and be like well my husband was 20
and i was 15.
you know
i got to be honest with you the
difference between 20 and 15 a 15 year
old is a [ __ ]
i i can't quite say a child but there
there's a massive age difference forget
about the legality of it
in most states other than mississippi
um
sorry [ __ ] with you guys um 22 to 16.
i mean you're talking about somebody
who's in the middle of high school
dating somebody who's graduated college
uh
that i don't know
i don't know about that all right
i
look can you at least understand why
this guy is that upset
and have you ever watched to catch a
predator i mean that it's not like
there's not like
evidently a zillion [ __ ] creeps out
there how many seasons of to catch a
predator did they do
i mean you would think like the amount
of people out there that are going
online trying to meet underage women you
wouldn't think that i mean
i would like to think
that there's maybe 40 people doing that
but there isn't
there's a bunch hundreds of thousands of
[ __ ] creeps out there doing that [ __ ]
so this guy's supposed to stay out of it
and roll the dice that maybe this guy
is a good guy like your husband well all
i can say is i hope that you're right
you've had fortunately you've had more
experience this
in this than i have because i would not
want to have experience in any shape
or form
in this and i don't think my family
would
um stay out of it
there would be major [ __ ] problems
there would be it's like dude you're 22
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you how did
you even meet my
sister you know how are you how are you
meeting sixteen-year-olds you [ __ ]
creep
uh you know what
maybe i'm ignorant here why don't you
write back again i want to hear the
story how you guys met
you know
was he teaching you how to add and
subtract
sorry the jokes are just too easy all
right
thanksgiving day special
billy crocker there's a new one betty
crocker billy crocker i like that and i
like to cook oh that's a good one
love your intensity when it comes to
bringing something to the table on
thanksgiving
absolutely no pun intended it's it's
really a no-brainer get good at making
something and get to a point where
you're automatic oh he's talking about
yeah like i was talking about a few
weeks ago when thanksgiving comes around
you got to have that dish that you just
[ __ ] can make and you throw down and
you take it to another level
all right everybody else should be doing
the same thing and then the end that's
the thanksgiving meal
um so this guy goes yeah you get a dish
down to where you're automatic how hard
can it be
uh you'll you'll never been ex
you'll never bend you've never been
expected to step out of your skill set
if you're baking breads no one will ever
expect you to bring the cranberry sauce
uh what's your go-to this year what's
nia's specialty
what's my go-to this year how about the
whole [ __ ] meal
dude i'll tell you right now
you guys think i'm a [ __ ] one-trick
pony i can make you a turkey dinner with
stuffing mashed potatoes my gravy game
is getting better i got to work on my
gravy game and i know that's crucial
all right
but my [ __ ] uh
my mashed potatoes not a [ __ ] lump in
them
all right enough butter to make you
slide off the chair
um as they say in new orleans that's bad
new orleans accent i admit it my
stuffing go [ __ ] yourself
all right
dude you don't understand the recipes
that i have access to all of my recipes
start with melt a stick of butter
and a third a cup of crisco in a pan
okay so you know it's delicious
um
yeah my stuffing
i don't my mashed potatoes are this [ __ ]
but nia is african-american so she likes
more sweet potatoes so i don't think
they uh
that side respects mashed potatoes
the way they should okay i feel like my
potato my my my
united colors of benaton whatever the
[ __ ] it is respect for for sweet
potatoes and mashed potatoes i think i'm
a little more
uh mature
than the lovely nia
um what's nia's specialty um
nia's she's just great at everything
she's one of those people that i i'll be
out in the kitchen like there's nothing
to eat what the [ __ ] i'm starving and
she'll be like what do you do there's
nothing to eat she comes out there and
she knows you got a couple things under
her arms
and i don't know i'm eating spaghetti or
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm eating
she somehow just throws it all together
or makes some ridiculous omelette
um
she's actually a true cook i'm a little
more robotic i'm um
i think i'm gonna become a a great cook
or or a better cook the way i became a
better comedian where at first i was a
joke writer and i was trapped in my act
and then i learned how to improv and
she's
kind of just watching her she kind of as
she cooks she's tasting it and doing all
that type of stuff where i just
they said to leave it in 15 minutes it's
been 15 minutes and i take it out um
um pies
i kind of got the whole thing dude from
start to finish my uh my appetizer game
is terrible
in fact i don't even know if i know how
to make one
i have no idea but dude i can make a pie
from [ __ ] scratch okay
i can look at you and tell you what all
your [ __ ] problems are as i'm making
the pie crust and not even look down
once i can just feel the texture
you know what i'm saying that's how many
[ __ ] pies i've made
all right
and i'll take that pie someday and i'll
bring it to your [ __ ] house
all right and i'll take a whole hunk of
it just and i'll just shove it right
down your throat and there's nothing
that you're gonna be able to say other
than thank you for that experience
all right as i'm shaking up the can of
whipped cream to give you a facial
you know what's funny about this my
attitude like cooking is the same
as like those dancers with their stupid
[ __ ] looks on their faces
take that [ __ ] look off of your
goddamn unless you just dunked on
somebody
unless you have a loaded [ __ ] pistol
pointed at my face you take that [ __ ]
look off of your goddamn grill
is your [ __ ] moon walking across the
stage like i'm in awe of you
i'm not saying it's not a not a great
skill to have but what you're doing
versus the look the look on your face is
so far down the [ __ ] street compared
to what the [ __ ] you're doing
is that
all the way back to those janet jackson
videos i miss you much oh ha that's too
much and she'd have this [ __ ] look in
her face and she's putting her fingers
in and she's hopping around and it was
amazing visually it was amazing to look
at but why do you have that [ __ ] look
on your face
why are you all dressed in these army
uniforms like you're fighting in a war
all right get back to the way it was all
right everybody five six seven eight
chenille
you know i just realized that shamil
shimazu were yiddish words i never knew
what it was i thought it was jewish guys
that ran the beer company that they
worked for
i know i'm not pronouncing them correct
shamil is the kind of guy who i guess
spills a drink and is shema
i can't say unless i sing the song
shamil shimazu
is the guy he spills it on
how funny is that
let me tell you guys how much i love
yiddish words i actually just looked up
a bunch because i wanted to learn some
more because they're [ __ ] hilarious
and they're fun to say
and uh i really like jewish humor
but uh i actually looked up and it was
like i knew i already knew 90 of them
there was so many that i was using and i
didn't even realize
did i already talk about this or did i
start to talk about i don't give a [ __ ]
it's the holiday week you guys got a
short week how psyched are you how
[ __ ] great is this is the work week
that we were supposed to have
remember uh
remember the jetsons
maybe oh god these three day work weeks
are murder
all right the yiddish handbook 40 words
you should know
um
all right there's so many that i use
shutsupa nerve
extreme arrogance
oh i've been using that wrong i thought
that man you had like oh hutzbas to get
up and go shuts but is oh that's funny
like shut the [ __ ] up
i don't need your arrogance a glitch
is a yiddish word
kibbits
klutz
kosher obviously
um
nosh is to nibble
schlep
i never knew sh there is
schlemiel is a clumsy inept person so
similar to a klutz
the kind of person who always spills his
su his soup
i know i'm butchering these sorry jewish
people
sh schlemazel is someone who with
constant bad luck
when the chameleon spills his soup he
probably spills it on the sh schlemazel
that's [ __ ] i'm sorry i know i
[ __ ] schmaltzy schmooze schmuck
we all use these words
shtick
i had no idea
i had no [ __ ] idea that these were
all these these were all yiddish words
you know what's a [ __ ] great yiddish
word too for your dick
schmeckle
isn't that [ __ ] perfect it just
sounds like what it is you can just hear
the trouble you're gonna get into with
it
ah what happened ah my [ __ ] schmeckle
did it again god damn it um
all right
here we go let's let's move on here oh
you know what i got to do some more
advertising so i don't read these too
late in the podcast so they don't
[ __ ] [ __ ] moan and complain
all right here we go here we go oh
there's only one more for this week look
at this short week
short list of uh
advertisers all right e-voice everybody
the uh the holidays are coming the
holiday season scooby-dooby-doo and
business and as a business owner you
know what that means crickets
right who's coming into your businesses
they're hanging up all the holiday cheer
face it the next couple of months are
the calm before the storm
now's the time to do something that will
dramatically dramatically help your 2014
e-voice
jesus what did i eat i can't even get
this out e-voice is a simple technology
that helps you make more money
you hear that people it's a simple
technology that's going to make you more
money if you're not paying attention now
you my friend are at jerk off with
e-voice toll-free or local numbers call
routing tools in a professional dial by
name directory your business will look
like a million bucks and with e-voice if
you could if you can't take a call they
will transcribe the voicemail and email
it directly to you you'll never be
caught off guard again e-voice has been
saving companies thousands of dollars
every month making them more efficient
and more productive
there is no quicker or easy way to
transform your business for 2014 and
with evoice you can try it before you
buy it what more do they have to do
right now you can get a free 30-day
trial to e-voice when you go to evoice
dot com slash bill burr or go to
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner that's evoice.com billboard or
banner
there you go now's the time to take
charge of your business and prepare for
a productive 2014.
all right i gave you the links
evoice.com
billboard or billboard.com and click on
the e-voice banner for your free 30-day
trial
there you go that's the deal
that's the advertising for this week
and now we're back to the back to the
letters
um holiday friend
billy oh
uh i've been seeing this girl for about
a month and a half
handful of dinners and some sex
very nice
you like to eat you like to [ __ ] who
doesn't like doing that
this guy's over here like hey what do
you want from me she's super cool but
i'm emotionally unavailable oh you son
of a get a bad father
bad parents what happened
huh
you get thrown in a burlap sack and
beating with a reed like [ __ ] uh dr
evil what happened to you
um he said i got too much stuff going on
with work to be thinking about a
relationship however i'm enjoying this
casual situation she seems to be happy
as well oh jesus dude you're going to
break her heart man
women don't look at this [ __ ] the way we
do she seems happy as well because she's
probably thinking it's going somewhere
is what i'm guessing
uh and then one day you'll be like yeah
you know i'm not feeling it and then
she's gonna start crying and be like
what the [ __ ] i thought we were just
[ __ ] and then she would that's all
you thought this was
that's all he was here this whole time
we went out we got ice cream you know
anyone it's like just picture seinfeld
crying that's what you're gonna hear why
would you do that
um
however i'm enjoying the casual
situation she seems to be happy as well
so what do i
what do i get her for christmas that
doesn't make it look like i've made room
for her toothbrush dude you shouldn't
get her anything for christmas
don't get her a [ __ ] thing for
christmas
don't [ __ ] her until after christmas
why are you filling up her heart with
hope don't do this i've done this you're
gonna hurt her
he goes i was thinking about some small
things a book and maybe a sweatshirt
from this place on the beach that she
likes
oh well isn't that thoughtful
dude get her a pack of fig newtons like
share a package of those let her know
where you stand
he said p.s the last gift i bought a
girl
was a few years back we've been dating
for three years
and she cheated on me oh we had been
dating for three years and she cheated
on me i found out over thanksgiving and
when it came time to give christmas
presents i handed her a frame with a
poem
the first part of the poem was super
sweet she was getting emotional then she
got to the last line which read
after these words your heart should feel
heated
but instead
i'm gonna peace cause [ __ ] you cheated
holy [ __ ]
wait a minute
is that a true story
i don't even care if you made it up you
have to write back
i want to hear what happened what the
[ __ ] did she say
jesus christ dude that's like
i'd expect like a that's like
that's really deep man that's really
clever that's really intelligent that's
the kind of thing a woman would do
you know we're usually just knees and
elbows like what did you suck his dick
you know just start screaming at him
because then you know you're in a full
nelson by some other [ __ ] jerk-off
dragging you away and you're in the
right
that's really uh that's really amazing
um i would i would say
i would say this uh
i oh wait this is my podcast person
texting me right now trying to call me
right now
he's getting on a plane so that's why
this podcast is late all right and also
i had to do this radio talk go [ __ ]
yourselves all right it's the holiday
week i'm sitting here my slippers
what are your thoughts um
my thoughts are you're really gonna hurt
this woman
because i feel like you haven't had a
conversation with her you said you said
however i'm enjoying this casual
situation and you said she seems to be
happy as well so that indicates to me
that you guys haven't talked
sat down and talked this out and i can
guarantee you
if this woman is anything like the women
that i've dated it's already too late
all right um
she might be happy thinking like oh wow
he's taking it's slow he's really
getting to know me
you know he got me a sweatshirt from
this place on the beach
that i like he's paying attention to me
he he
is noticing things about me you know it
is dude you are actually you're actually
a relationship
guy but this other woman ruined you
and you got to get that hate out of your
heart
or the defensiveness out of your heart
before you should be messing around with
somebody like that like right now what
you should be doing
is just going out and just
i don't know working on yourself while
[ __ ] everything that moves or or
maybe not
you shouldn't be going like don't hurt
this like i don't know what's going on
because this is still very very vague
but don't hurt this woman because that
last one hurt you i've made that mistake
it's a bad it's bad dude and i and i i'm
not judging you for being in that
situation because you're a guy and you
shouldn't understand them but
now that i understand him a little bit
more uh
you know
i'm you're headed for a [ __ ] if i had
to guess
you're headed for a rough christmas or
shortly after christmas
you know when she goes you want to meet
my parents and i could wear the
sweatshirt that you got me from the
place on the beach that you like
you know and she'll bring that up right
after she just blew you and your saturn
and you'd be like yeah you know i was
gonna watch the holiday bowl instead
with some buddies of mine i'm gonna
watch the outback state house steakhouse
[ __ ] bowl
and then she'd be like well wait a
minute like why
well i i don't understand and then you'd
be like and then you're going to be
starting to sense like wait well what do
you mean you understand
i just invited you
to meet my parents and you like you
don't want to meet them these
i mean i'm a little offended i mean
these are
these are my parents
jaw starts hanging down you can't even
understand what she's saying i said
okay
and you're like and then she starts
crying and then if you're like most guys
you get mad because you're uncomfortable
oh you're gonna [ __ ] cry now i can't
believe
that i would be crying and you would say
something
who are you
how are you
okay let me get out of the car let me
out of that car she [ __ ] rolls into a
snow drift i'm telling you dude you know
you don't want to go down this road i i
got a bad feeling
i got a bad feeling about this one man
um just make sure that she's enjoying
this the same way you are
dude who wouldn't like to be with the
super cool girl that you don't have to
[ __ ] be emotionally involved with
who's coming over and banging you and
let me tell you something dude this is
not a hundred percent on you so don't
feel guilty because she also hasn't sat
down and had the conversation
maybe she has her baggage maybe she sat
down and said that to some other guy and
it scared her away and she said okay now
to stop didn't i bring up where is this
guy that said
um coffee shop girl
dear illiterate [ __ ]
i'm not illiterate i'm just not good at
reading out loud it doesn't make me
illiterate i can still read the words
ugh did that didn't that just sound like
somebody illiterate i'm smart
fredo
all right i'm a young guy oh my god some
21 year old kid just called me an
illiterate [ __ ]
and you know what i gotta take that on
the chin
i gotta sit here at my locker at the end
of the reading game i take full
responsibility for that loss i i got no
one to blame myself
i'm a young guy 21. and i have kinda and
i kind of have a thing for a chick who
works at my local coffee shop please
tell me she's not 16. i don't want to
read another one of these
uh the idea of chatting her up while
she's working always seems weird to me
mainly because i know she has to listen
just give me some quick tips so i don't
come off as a weirdo love the podcast
and thanks dude are you [ __ ] kidding
me
this is the perfect situation
all right
oh she works at the local coffee shop
oh i thought you worked with her [ __ ]
that's the perfect that's the perfect
situation if you work with somebody that
you're into
as far as you know being able to talk to
him it's not weird at all
and uh you can make them laugh and that
type of thing then they get into you but
then the bad thing is is then you start
[ __ ] somebody you're working with
and you got a pretty good chance that
you're not gonna make the playoffs with
that one you know
and you're gonna have to rebuild
and it's going to be ugly then you're
going to lose your fan base and the fan
base will be the other chicks at work
that you probably should have been
[ __ ] instead of that [ __ ] but
anyways
all right
so you're walking into this coffee shop
and there's a girl there working there
that you like
and you don't want to start because it's
going to seem weird all right well
what's weird about that is
to try to do it in line
is you're really dealing with a uh
a short period it's like a vine you're
going to try to hit on her in the span
that it takes to sh to watch a vine you
like that
you like that reference
trying to be hip to the dubstep [ __ ]
generation
is dubstep already over have you moved
on to something else
um
that [ __ ] look on your goddamn face
all right i could break you in half like
a pencil will you stop looking at me
like you can kick the [ __ ] out of me
while you're dancing maybe that's what
it is maybe that's it's just the funny
something something funny about it
attitude dancing um can you guys send me
some clips to some of the funniest
attitude dancing you can find or maybe
put some together
right there you go you know what i love
is when you guys take clips from my
podcast and then you play the audio
underneath like some of the the uh the
animation that people have done is it's
[ __ ] so creative
like that one when that guy did the one
for when i sang that song do you know
what it means to miss new orleans that's
where my baby goes and the guy did the
whole
animation of it i was talking about
somebody throwing up and when the word
throw up came in it it looked like it
was launched out of somebody's mouth
like it arced its way in
really creative so how about uh
as i'm talking about these people
dancing
just have just put come on you guys you
all you [ __ ] youngsters you know how
to use computers just put the audio
underneath and just have that kind of
dancing
over the top like that's the video i
don't know how to say it technically
anyways so let's get back to this thing
see
all right first thing you got to do
is uh
i would you got to drink your coffee
there does she come around
this is so hard how do i give you advice
all i can give you i can't tell you what
to say
because i never know what to say until
i'm there in the moment and something
pops in
unless she's really good looking and
then at that age i would just get
[ __ ] intimidated and be like i'm just
gonna sit here
eat my bran muffin
um
ah what would you do i don't know do you
got something coming up that you can
invite her to
this is what i would do i would come
there frequently enough that she starts
to recognize you all right and then ease
your way into kind of knowing her i
guess i would do that and then you have
something if you got a [ __ ]
whatever you kids do nowadays
you know if there's a big ecstasy
shipment coming to town and you're gonna
meet the truck there with your glow
sticks and you got an extra pair of glow
sticks that you could hand to her
uh
maybe you could do that
something where i'm just flailing here
dude don't [ __ ] ask me coffee shot i
went did i never picked up any girl that
worked at a [ __ ] coffee shop
i was good on the subway in new york
but that was because there would always
be some weirdo doing something weird and
then you could just lock in with the
other person
you know like look at this [ __ ]
maniac and then you could make some say
something funny about that
you'd make them laugh and then you were
in that the gym
coffee shops that's out of my wheelhouse
so i would just say go there enough
where she starts to recognize you
try to extend the conversation each time
you order
and then blah blah blah but but the
thing is you can't keep coming in there
because you're really going to look like
a creep so i would say within three
visits give yourself three visits
on the third visit you just gotta
[ __ ] ask her
you know if she's seen anybody and have
something to invite her to that's going
to be a fun thing
don't just be like i just want to take
you out sometime and maybe i could pull
it out you could just look at it you
don't have to touch it don't do it like
that have something to do
an event
ladies like the events
and i don't know what they're into at
your age but um
i don't know the first time
is too weird you gotta have unreal game
that i don't have so i can't [ __ ]
give you advice second time
she's getting to know you and then third
time you go for it right
swing for the [ __ ] fence
just say look cutie pie i don't work
here
all right
so i know this is what am i supposed to
do i'm attracted to you all right
[ __ ] sakes put down the goddamn coffee
and and come to me to to the to the
burning man thing
i got plenty of sunscreen and ecstasy
and uh you know
and it's not a sex thing i mean i would
hope it would eventually turn into it
but more like a lovingly thing like the
kind of thing where i wouldn't tell my
friends what we did because i care for
you kind of thing you know
maybe we lay in the dirt and roll around
next to that thing that's on fire right
i have no coffee shop game hey anybody
out there have coffee shop game
i don't drink coffee that's the thing
all right it's [ __ ] gross it tastes
like dirty water and it burns my mouth
so i don't [ __ ] with it
and that just takes all that coffee shop
[ __ ] right out the [ __ ] window
they always just seem like the
coffee shop people to me always seem
like hipsters like they just were over
everything
you know
so if you're over everything you're over
everything the [ __ ] grand canyon
you're over that my dumb ass is coming
in there what the you're not gonna be
over that
lack of pigment
uh all right the mall
billy holiday
very nice i am going on all a day i'm
going to italy i'm going to miss
thanksgiving
um what's your plan of attack when you
enter a mall
are you on a mission or are you a window
shopper
do you have a favorite gift you've ever
been given and what's your go-to mall
food
panda express taco bell sparrow pizza
sparrow pizza sucks
it always looks good i'll tell you but
it really fills you up i usually go with
the chicken parmesan and that
that one a little sketti
then i get on the plane and i start
farting into that [ __ ] flotation
device beneath me
or perhaps a fancy sandwich from obam
paul
they don't there's nothing fancy about
that other than the [ __ ] name
um aubon pan if you're still living in
the 90s always making fun of the place
thanks and gobble gobble go [ __ ]
yourself all right
my plan of attack when i enter a mall i
only go to a mall when i need something
that's it
and i know what i want and i know where
it is and i go in there and when it's
not there i'm like oh what the [ __ ] and
then i leave
um i do not window shop
at malls
i hate malls
it's just all those [ __ ] people and
it just makes me
they're just depressing
when i was younger it was great you
walked around there was all these
[ __ ]
that was like what you did
you go to the mall and then you ran into
girls that you were in your grade
and they'd be like hi bill and i'd be
like hi
then i'd walk away my face all red
and then i was like well why didn't i
say something i hate myself and then i
went then where would i sit down and eat
um
i don't like panda express
uh
taco bell no fast food mexican food why
don't you just play russian roulette
that's taco bell is russian roulette for
your ass
um sparrow pizza same [ __ ] thing
where would i where would i go
well if i had to choose smallers i'd go
to i'd go to sparrow
um
there's usually some barbecue thing
i don't know you know what i hate is
when they had they'd have that little
sweet and sour chicken on the toothpicks
and then that overly smiling asian woman
would come over and ask you if you
wanted one
and it's just like didn't you like
poison the toys
i don't want to eat that right
how archie bunker was that i just don't
like it just [ __ ] creeps me out that
you're walking around with food
like where where was that where did you
get that
you know you're on this side of the
counter like on that side i already know
there's enough health code violations at
sparrow pizza taco bell and panda
express enough rat turds in that [ __ ]
that you know i should run out of here
right now but now you're on this side
where people are sneezing you're on this
side of the sneeze glass walking around
with that [ __ ] you don't even have it
covered
stuck with a little [ __ ] toothpick
and then you got that other thing over
there where people stick their used
toothpicks will you get that [ __ ]
glazed chicken out of my face there
smiley
beat it um
yeah i'm too old to eat at those places
when i was younger i ate at mickey d's
o.a mcdonald's i was a mcdonald's guy
uh kentucky fried chicken cold i could
never eat it hot that grease when it's
hot makes me sick to my stomach when
it's cold it's [ __ ] ecstasy and i
would melt into the rug into the rug
like i was on in train spotting
um
i liked friendlies
back in the day
get myself a nice burger melt and a
[ __ ] gym dandy nice 3 000 calories to
the [ __ ] heart and then i'd walk out
of there and go play frisbee football
because that's what she did back then
with my [ __ ] white socks yanked up to
underneath my patella
um
ken patella
all right that's the podcast for this
week people i don't know what to tell
you
all right i hope you guys have a
wonderful thanksgiving my european tour
is about to start i'm going over to
italy and speaking of going to like the
first bowl ever i'm gonna go to the
colosseum so if you're in italy and
you're gonna be over there look for me
in the colosseum
um
it hasn't even hit me yet then i'm gonna
be i actually we land in charles de
gaulle airport in paris and then we
we fly over to italy and it's an
unbelievable
is something to give thanks for it's an
unbelievable privilege
that uh
i can do what i do for a living and
enough people come out to see me that i
can take the lovely nia with me over to
uh
to italy and so thank you to everybody
who's come out to my shows this year and
all the years past
um
and uh i'm really looking forward to
giving everybody their money's worth
over in europe because i plan on doing
this for the rest of my career uh
doing stand-up and traveling over to
europe
and i'm gonna tour australia next year
and canada the canada one's going down
in march
and uh we're working on those dates
right now and i just plan to keep on
expanding it i'm hoping to also do new
zealand
and uh i know there's a gig in india i
mean why the [ __ ] wouldn't i go
i want to go over there and see what
that's like
right
tokyo and all those places i plan on you
know you only go around [ __ ] once and
i really believe that when you're dead
you don't go anywhere i think you just
go in the [ __ ] ground
and you make the soil rich for other
living things
so
if you got a comedy clump
i'm [ __ ] gonna try to hit it before i
die something i want to see the great
wall of china i want to see all of that
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] wouldn't you
i want you know something somebody came
up to me from saudi arabia and gave me
some currency
it was really [ __ ] cool it said 50
i'm like dude you're giving me 50 bucks
he's like yeah it's like worth 15 over
here
like it's still 15 bucks
so um
i'm really into all of that stuff so i'm
hoping to uh see as much as i i can and
i couldn't do it without you guys coming
out to my show so there you go there's a
warm fuzzy ending me giving thanks on
the week of thanksgiving and that's the
podcast for this week go [ __ ] yourselves
um
for people in los angeles if you haven't
heard i'm doing a new year's eve gig at
the will turn theater with the entire
rose bowl tailgate syndicate
myself
joe bartnick jason lawhead and andrew
themless we're all going to be uh
we're all going to be telling jokes that
night and it's going to be phenomenal
and uh there's not a lot of tickets left
it's going to be a great [ __ ] show
come on down bring in the new year with
us um and that's it okay now this is the
official end go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great thanksgiving and i'll talk to you
next week from italy i think i'll be in
italy maybe i'll be in london at that
point i don't know all right that's it
[ __ ] you